[Music]
[Music]
so
oh hey look it's happening and it's a
monday go figure welcome
to fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i am
mark bernardin
hey ho ho ho
um it was negligible whether there would
be a show tonight kids i just got back
literally uh not too long ago i went to
florida to do two shows on friday and
saturday
in del rey and in orlando and that were
wonderful outs outdoors socially
distanced and stuff
then on sunday i spent mother's day with
my sainted mother
nice in the orlando area then this
morning
i left florida flew to austin to
open a movies at austin city limits live
so uh cut the ribbon and all that stuff
and then flew here to los angeles
where i'm now engaged with you fine
people so mark
three states in six hours
i have not done that
ah man time when you get three states in
a three-way
it's interstate action as we like to
call it is man
hard core interstate action
um so it's a miracle that uh we're
actually
uh getting to do a show but that's
because uh we're dedicated kids
dedicated to uh
to uh of the art here and dedicated to
talking to our guest tonight
who will have joining us um momentarily
and whatnot
uh and we're not gonna have him all
night so
we're gonna jump right in
uh when that happens and that guest kids
is none other than the man responsible
for the new captain america
for falcon and the winter soldier strike
that captain america
and the winter soldier uh showrunner
malcolm spellman is going to be with
us here tonight and we're going to geek
out with him man
indeed yeah we will get to the the bulk
of the show including
another thrilling installment of how
hairy are your balls
let's tell you about them and how to
make them less hairy i know it's the
radio drama that the world's been asking
for
everyone always wants to know what to do
with nut hair mark
and they always tune in here to fat
batman beyond to find out what to do
about it
they don't come to us for the big stuff
for the issues political
governance no no no when they want to
know what to do with ball hair
fat man beyond is the place to go man
and
when you come here you know what we tell
you get your ass over to
to manscaped.com uh do me a favor go
there right now literally right now
manscaped.com and you're gonna get 20
off and free shipping with the code
fatman20
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping
at manscape.com and use the code
fatman20
all one word unlock your confidence and
always use the right tools for the job
with manscaped mark
uh the thing that i love about this
particular ad read is the puns
and my favorite pun is we're providing a
pubic service
this is a pubic service announcement
they're good man they didn't have to go
into
[ __ ] manscaping they could have went
into stand-up they're good
they really could have man they really
could have um and hey the the big news
the reason why there's a pubic service
announcement is that they have
successfully created
the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer which is now
available for purchase
in the usa and canada and it is just
it's fresh on the stands man
fresh in the stands to make your balls
as fresh as they can be we're
we're some of the first people to try
the 4.0 and they sent it to us
before they release it to the world man
because membership has its privileges
kids
and it's incredible um not only does it
do the job
of [ __ ] uh you know mowing the lawn
so to speak
it is a powerful vibratory device
do with that what you will if you tape a
toothbrush to it you could literally
have an electric toothbrush as well
also very powerful but kind and gentle
and it's got ceramic like skin safe
technology
so good it almost seems as manscaped
work with elon musk's engineers
to ensure your testes are as safe as
possible
i first time ever tried to groom
my balls mark i was uh but a lad in high
school
trying to keep things a little more kept
than they were
and uh i went down with uh
a pair of scissors and you should never
never
go near that area with a pair of
scissors man leave it to the
professionals
leave it to manscape because i still got
a scar on my nuts
that's what happens when you use those
big [ __ ] art class scissors man
especially if they're like lefty
scissors yeah you're a righty
they gave me the green handled ones man
how is that supposed to cut with that
so let me tell you something kids thank
the lord
manscaped is here for us man i wish
they had existed way back in the day i
wouldn't have
malformed myself man i'm gonna be
calling you
nick yes what makes their trimmer
different than all the other trimmers
it's a passover question isn't it a new
multi-function
on and off switch can engage a travel
lock created for people who like to
travel
and or even if you don't like to try i
don't like to travel but i have to
travel
and when i'm on the road i want my ball
hair growing all long and shaggy
got to keep it tight so you can take it
with you travel on this new
lawnmower 4.0 man gives you the ability
to turn the 4000k
led spotlight on and off when needed for
more precise shavings a light built into
it and [ __ ]
so you can use it to find your keys at
night as well man multiple uses of this
new trimmer even allows you to customize
your trim
all over through additional guard
lengths
with sizes 1-4 that's like sometimes you
want to take your beard off
but you can't like take it all off you
just want to leave some so you shave it
down and stuff you could do that
with your with your your balls need a
goatee
then here's how you get it yes
absolutely so this is why
this is a sleek two-tone matte and gloss
finish
even features a hot foil stamped black
chrome manscape logo man show that
mower off loud and proud take it out
show your neighbors look at my lawn
mower
and then it'll be like what we'll be
like look you can use it right in front
of them and shear yourself like a
[ __ ] sheep and whatnot
don't be impressed they will so get 20
off and free shipping with the code
fatman20 at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
with the code fatman20
unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools for the job
with manscaped we thank the good folks
at manscape for being a proud sponsor of
this week's uh
edition of fat man beyond let me tell
you something manscaped beside
themselves right now
they didn't know when they were putting
down their hard-earned ad dollar
that they were gonna be putting uh that
ad dollar on a show
that was gonna have a quality guest
ladies and gentlemen never mind this
robert kirkman [ __ ]
we're always throwing your way no more d
and
and z great guests from now on all
a-listers man and tonight's guest he may
not be as rich
as robert kirkman but who is except for
elon musk maybe
so tell them who we got tonight mark
tonight we have
the head writer of the world's biggest
television show
falcon and winter soldier slash captain
american winter soldier
malcolm spellman
welcome aboard thank you for making the
time um
are you exhausted at this point now
the show it's been intense um
i've never been through nothing like
this um
i think i've done a good job
like like i know you know people say
they avoid the press i've done a pretty
i've been pretty serious about that
but like i did a lot of press and i
occasionally
i mean you know about this from having
runs in this business
there's a reality to you to you have
moments
and you've got to capitalize on them but
not give in to them
and so i'm figuring that out so it's
it's been it's been a trip
it's been a trip malcolm uh i can't
identify with that because you are
successful and that's what happens to
successful people
me and mark we look at these successful
people from the outside so we can't
identify
with this moment that you're living in
shut up
i've seen you have a couple of runs my
friend
um runs man like before we dove in i
went and looked at the imdb
and i was expecting after the quality
show that i watched and i you know i
i've said many times i wasn't like
jumping in for
falcon and the winter soldier when they
announced it i was like one division and
they said i'll watch that as well
and then i absolutely fell in love with
it masterfully made and so i'm like all
right this guy must have a
long [ __ ] tail going way back to like
hill street blues or some such
[ __ ] and it's does it really begin with
empire yeah so the way it went was
in 2000 late 2000 i broke in with a spec
script out of nowhere right
and i had that initial run of heat and
i sympathize what's the what's the old
boy's name who wrote boondock states
oh uh yeah uh but they did it
whatever i wasn't as hot as him and i
didn't go down as far as him right
but i had a similar thing where like the
town fell in love with me for a couple
years
i was a hot dude up i was fresh out of
the streets i didn't know
have any idea how to mount the career
and so i went from being in the streets
to [ __ ] coming out of nowhere
inviting me
to premieres and i don't really know how
to explain it to you guys
i really wasn't in this business so it
was
like being put into a tv show and then
after a few years of that
death and so between that
death and empire you know
a little bit of chair like i went like
four and a half almost five years with
nowhere
and then little charity here lost all my
reps
a little charity here a little charity
there from people whatever
but made most of my money outside this
industry until until empire came
it was like most of my career i've
failed i've had a 20-year career
most of it i failed you know what i'm
saying yeah well i mean i
would i understand i'm not sitting here
going yeah i know you failed
it's unbelievable though to me that you
sell a spec
in 2000 and for those who are like
what's that spec script is like
you know when you're an outsider and you
write a script and even sometimes you're
an insider you write a script
unassigned and you just send it in and
the bidding war can begin
and then you know based on this reaction
around town people invite you in and
stuff
what was the name of the script malcolm
and did they ever make it
they did not make it i got when i got it
i don't want to out people but it's an
important story as to what i was dealing
with so
it was called core it was about a black
kid
who uh wanted a skater and wanted to go
to the x games you know
kind of like the eight mile story or
whatever right uh
we're we're reworking it now and uh
uh uh you know that was out the box back
then this is like a year before
save the last dance in about two years
before fast and furious so
the term multiculti didn't exist right
and
uh uh but it was a strip like
it it had some sauce to it right like i
think people did feel like i was a real
comer
and because i've been outside the system
for years just
writing scripts getting notes and
literally not even sending them nobody
i'm saying so
um and i remember um as i was going
through the development process
you know i got the note the note of
notes which was back so this is about a
black kid
he's hooking up with a burnt up tony
hawk type everyone he's hanging out with
is white
the love interest is white or whatever
but we get to know
um um um this hurts me more to tell you
than you to hear this
but we have to change the lead character
to a white dude
um because it has to be 100 white and
it's important
because that's how bad hollywood was
back then
that that was appropriate to say right
you have one black character in here and
that is too many
yeah it's like just if we could just
paint over this area i think we've got
to go project
and and it's not like this person was an
outlier
go look at the movies that was being
made back then it's just what it was
you know what i'm saying i don't even
blame them um and
man i couldn't function in that world i
couldn't i couldn't make [ __ ] happen
um um and as you know even though that
was the beginning of the heat it was
also the beginning of the end
because what this business is telling
you is
we're going through you know they go
through their waves out here like you
look at the 90s
there was a moment where singleton and
spike and matty rich and all these
brothers were making movies
and sisters too and then on tv you had
fresh prince and martin and that
are done upn and uh wb all of that's
happened at the same time and then gone
right and that's what it does and so i
was coming right in
after all that [ __ ] was gone and you
know
it was it was brutal man it was a brutal
it's a brutal thing to be up against man
someone this was weird then right
because you had like
cosby show and different world and you
know there was a crest and a wave of
black entertainment
that vanished by like 2003. yep
like fell off a cliff yep yep
and and the argument i mean
it's just it's [ __ ] cruel because the
argument for it
is some [ __ ] and you just can't
it's a completely illogical these
[ __ ] truly believe the [ __ ]
they're saying
like i got friends who have now evolved
past it
but my own friends used to tell me well
you gotta understand
black leads mean you can't do this
overseas or whatever that and it's just
not true
but it don't matter if they believe it
to the point they are willing to say it
to you
as like hey malcolm two things two plus
two is four
and black people hurt box office
overseas
they don't hurt sports they don't hurt
music and they don't hurt in box office
a lot of times
but in all the other times they hurt
back up you know and
that that thing is now emerging in tv
really loudly it's coming back it's a
[ __ ] awful monster
um um they don't say it explicitly
but you can see it happening anyway it
was i didn't know how to navigate that
[ __ ]
and my [ __ ] died you know what i'm
saying so when you got the call from
empire was that like a relief
or and when was it something what do you
know
i'm not enough that's right did you
i had a hard time with it man like
like i always been like the reason
like i always been someone who was
willing to bet on myself
um to a fault and i mean that like to a
fault you you have to
that just doesn't work not in this
business at least it didn't work for me
and when
empire came i'm trying to you know i
want to be
you probably have a lot of viewers in
the industry so i want to be
first of all i it is the most one of the
most important moments in my life
you don't say i'm going to acknowledge
that i didn't know like the idea of me
being on staff
because i just despite not working
despite
literally being making my money outside
of hollywood
if you're not in hollywood you still
haven't learned [ __ ]
right so i still don't know nothing i'm
15 years into my career now
and i don't really know [ __ ] so i feel
like oh [ __ ]
i'm taking this low-level staff job is
this a step back
nobody knows it's a hit you know what
i'm saying and
man it was existential for me man like
my revenues
all these meetings i had managers at
this time i did not have agents
um and they were like bro
they got real me they're like man you
ain't working
fox likes you if you tell them no
because i said no to uh
uh i'm willing to say this out loud
because my homework uh
chris morgan had this show gang related
and he tried to get me on that and i was
like nah
i'd heard some you know whatever it just
wasn't for me
and they were he was like you know my
manager was like bro if you say no to
this one
there's not no hard feelings fox is
gonna say this oh i get it
what we do he doesn't dig and man you
know so i i listened to my team and
jumped on it
and uh uh yeah one of the best things
that ever happened to me
and so how long were you there and
before you went someplace else because
it seems like after that bang bang bang
and then suddenly
falcon and the winter soldier it's
it's you know i talked to my my friends
like i
because i know so many [ __ ] writers
right and i see
so much false humility i try
not to have it when i'm doing interviews
because i know how you and mark and
everyone else talks behind the scenes
you know i'm saying i know everybody
thinks they're brilliant right
and i just wish people would be more
honest about it because the stories
would be a little more pure right
right i got embraced on empire
danny lee and eileen was like
oh this [ __ ] is he's
he's he's serious you know what i'm
saying like
whoever he is you know i'm saying he's
making a mark there's no doubt about
that
none of them will tell you different so
once
i finally got in the game and started
getting to other situations and i'm
looking at the competition
i'm like oh my god you know what i'm
saying i'm about to if this is if they
leave me in here
i'm gonna eat everybody's food you know
what i'm saying and i got a witness like
uh uh uh this is about a whole separate
separate issue not empire but i called
one of my buddies who's a big big a-list
screenwriter i'm like
yes if this is what i if this is who i
gotta be
i'm good and you know to run and and the
run speaks for itself
after that you know i just couldn't get
footing before then
to really show what i could do
um but it was definitely like once i got
once i got
in and that's the thing i think people
gotta understand
whether or not i'm remarkable doesn't
mean [ __ ]
first of all people have to have a
reason to give me opportunities
you know our industry every venture is
closer to 100 million dollars than it is
one million dollars
i'm saying in general and and
and the reason people
hire you is not because you're great or
brilliant or talented
it is about something that translates
easily
i was on empire for the first three
years right
this is the biggest show on tv that
translates
you know what i'm saying yeah don't dang
you know i don't think anyone's read me
since empire you know what i'm saying
like for a gig
right they don't even know if i can
write what i'm saying
so anyway yeah success succeeds
so were you a marvel kid growing up or
were you a comics guy at all yeah yeah i
i
i don't think they allow you through
them doors they can smell it you know
what i'm saying
they can smell it and i'm from berkeley
um we had two legendary shops and like
it seemed like every city has a
legendary shop now but you know
it is i'm talking late 70s early 80s as
a little kid right
everybody didn't have legendary shops
back then we had comics and comics
and then later best of two worlds um so
we grew up i was a neighborhood kid i'm
a real neighborhood kid you know what
i'm saying like i've
you know i'm i i came into hollywood
with legal baggage and all that [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying
um but because you know berkeley and the
bay area is just different you know what
i'm saying like you'll see
[ __ ] in the comic book shore
who go rob a bank you know what i'm
saying
a little bit later it's just a different
breed of person out there
we grew up we grew up with them books we
grew up with a deep relationship with
the people at the shops they knew us by
name
and um you know it is you know i
remember the
like my memory is bad but i remember
the warlock series that sort of predated
the infinity uh wars you know what i'm
saying oh yeah the adam warlock
yeah yeah like i i i my game is
fairly deep you know what i'm saying and
so they knew that when i when i when i
when i came up tomorrow
they could tell i mean they won't [ __ ]
with you if
i i don't think so anyway the impression
i get is that's a requirement
so who who how quickly do you get to
kevin feige asap
you mean that right like you're first
meeting in they're like this is the guy
second
second meeting um so i come in i meet
with nate moore who's one of their
senior execs you know what i'm saying
um which turned out to be a blessing for
me because marvel you know has a system
that we will not be talking about on
camera but which i learned to embrace
and love
but you need a guide you know what i'm
saying you need someone to guide you
through it they
i say this they are not doing that [ __ ]
by accident that run is not at all by
accident
and so i pitched to nate and nate who's
a little bit military and how he does
[ __ ]
went soft and was like [ __ ] it i love
this pitch
here's some notes i'm hooking you up
with kevin in the in the parliament and
the
all the other senior producers and um i
get chronic migraines
and i had a migraine on the day i went
into kevin but i had
also done something i was too eager and
i'd taken
every note and i'd taken them all
literally and i kind of just
jammed them in there and the pitch
didn't have the same flow
i bombed the pitch nate who does not
pull punches like yeah that that pitch
was no good
and so like a month or two pass and i
gotta assume
that basically i was out and they were
hearing all the other pictures you know
i'm saying
the way marvel works which is you know
this bro from doing mark youtube
probably working if you work in features
they not in features there's a literally
a [ __ ] checklist
here's the writers who i can hire
without losing my job
i don't i don't have to read none of
them that i'm just going he's available
he's available no it's always he
he's available he's available he's
available or not right and then they
find one and they plug them in and
that's how it goes right
and and marvel because the the culture
is different
nate basically this is my assumption
with the way i bomb that pitch
nate just told kevin you know that dude
who sucked that's the guy for the show
you know what i'm saying and i ended up
getting a call how
how how black was that pitch by which i
mean to say
how much did you already know going in
that you wanted to tell a story about
blackness in america and blackness in
the military and the burdens
that a black man has to carry in a
superheroic world like how much did you
have of that
mark i was at 90 i'm from debate bro i
went to
high school with huey newton's niece you
know what i'm saying
i was at i was at 90 blackness just off
the first pitch
um um they knew what it was and and
and and and they knew like whoever was
gonna do it was gonna have to come at it
from that angle just because
we live in the reality we live in you
know what i'm saying and
the stars and stripes do represent what
they represent
and anthony mackie's black
uh are you i mean philosophically are
you
team isaiah or are you team sam just
personally not saying like
picking a horse in the show but do you
come to it from a place
of hope like sam does or do you come
from a place of experience
the way isaiah does 100 isaiah and one
of the things
that was important to me was
at no point do we say isaiah is wrong
like we want to do something a little
bit different like you know i've written
a million stories that are quote hero's
journey and [ __ ] like that
and you always had this moment these
moments of darkness where you're
confronting your fears or you're
confronting
whatever the different manifestations of
it right isaiah is the living embodiment
of
sam's doubt right the same did not take
that shield
because you could say it's because of
steve rogers whatever
but don cheadle is there for a reason
you know what i'm saying
and he didn't take that shield because
he knew
what he was going to end up saying at
the end of this movie millions of people
were going to hate him for it and he
didn't even know if it was appropriate
right like
i don't even know if it's cool to take
it i don't it did
it's this country and the relationship
with it is too weird right
and isaiah is the embodiment of that at
no point in my opinion did isaiah ever
say anything that was wrong
and we wanted sam to not overcome that
doubt
we wanted sam to become capped in the
face of that doubt
with like i don't even know if this
shit's gonna work
when i know millions of people are gonna
hate me and i still gotta do it because
that ties directly in a weird way
there's a lineage to what isaiah did
isaiah knew when he fought for this
country they're gonna burn across as
long as long when he came home
you know what i'm saying and he still
went and did it you know what i'm saying
and so i feel like sam is continuing
that legacy
of knowing and acknowledging
that this fight must happen
uh in the face of the fact that this
fight might not be winnable
was there ever a chance that you were
going to
do flashbacks with isaiah
i don't think i can answer that i
they're pretty nice to me like i [ __ ] up
a lot you know what i'm saying
right and and but i want to be
respectful because they have not smacked
my hand in a while
um so i'ma try and be better about fair
enough and we don't want to lead you
down that path how about this
how close was your initial pitch
the one before you bombed and then two
months later got the call back
how close is the initial pitch to what
we watched
um i got to be careful on this one
because i think it's a great story
since you're saying pitch i want you to
extrapolate
the initial pitch
a million miles different except for
this the characters
a million miles different and
now as a as a writer and and i based on
the conversation the brief conversation
that we've had malcolm i can tell that
like
the written word has deep meaning to you
you you're a writer we can just hear it
smell it is it difficult
for somebody with an independent vision
or a vision period
to move into a place
where there are so many like why you
can't do that
you can't do that yeah it's it is very
difficult at first
and then it's amazing when you embrace
it and
it's like the matrix opens up and you're
like oh this is why these [ __ ]
are winning you know what i'm saying
like you are part of this giant [ __ ]
organism
that they only understand half the time
right but
they're so accustomed to it and i do
think like from my disposition
it was emotionally really hard you know
i'm saying like i'm
you know that's what i'm sensing like it
just it doesn't
it's not saying like he can't be a team
player but you
you have a voice it's very clear and
they have a voice that you know people
gel nicely with that's how those movies
seem to happen
i i i i'm very very collaborative but
i'm
also very very clear and
forceful like i don't think anyone
that's ever worked with me
would ever say that like for me my
mantra on running a writer's room
is of the best day i have in a running a
writer's room
none of my ideas on that board so let me
say that i'm not one of those
[ __ ]
that thinks i don't buy into all to auto
or anything in our industry
right um that said it's one of the
reasons i'm able to do that
is i'm clear i know what we're trying to
do and
i can communicate that so that everyone
can get fired up and do their best
version
and and it was it took some getting used
to
their process and man like nate and zoey
they assigned you two execs who are in
the room with you
that has like you know i got irked at
these [ __ ] at the uh
the uh uh av club who were acting like i
was being fake
about really being impressed with and
enjoying the experience right
um they're like he tries to spin it as
it and it's not i wouldn't even do that
i just would just not answer
but i found it to be amazing once you
once you give into it first of all it's
not like you're not leading
you know what i'm saying but you are
just mindful
of the fact that people who pay your
bills are
also right there in a room with you
right now
kevin here's one of things that's unique
about the marvel creator producers
their system as far as i know no other
studio does this
nate and zoey get assigned one project
they are with that project from the
beginning of outline when they sit
in the room with the writers this is
every marvel movie right
through script onto set
through post they don't do no other
projects so and
for just for context for those watching
normally a studio exec has 20
projects that they're overseeing what
malcolm's saying is that
two execs will have one project that
they shepherd
all the from cradle the grave without
working on anything else
yep wow and and nate's been doing that
[ __ ] for like 12 years
with ryan coogler with the russos with
you know what i'm saying
yeah and so their bedside manners
impeccable
like they work with [ __ ] writers you
know i'm saying like that's the thing is
like
people think they're in there saying
here's what to do creatively
they can pitch as well as anyone you're
going to get in there right
the first three times they do it it's
humiliating
because you're like this is a suit but
then you're realizing
this [ __ ] all he does is make
movies you know i'm saying that's that's
that's what he does and so you you
you've read me correctly i i have a
fragile disposition in certain ways
and it really [ __ ] me up at first and
then when i embraced it and i had a
great i sat with nate and zoe
and told him where i was uncomfortable
and man once we formed that creative
family it was
[ __ ] magic it was ma everything just
was
it was yeah it was great and it helps
that you're dealing with
characters who've been handled by
so many people like you realize at a
certain point i would imagine like well
i mean
i don't have the marvel experience but
you know when i was working on masters
of the universe the netflix
cartoon with mark the whole idea was
like
all right so many other people have
have handled this and have added spokes
to the wheel
and if we're lucky we get to add another
strong
spoke but like you know it's tough to
feel
like completely like this is mine
because it belongs to so many other
people before you ever get to touch it
and the best you can hope for is that
you define it
so that going forward everybody thinks
of that character in conjunction with
you vice versa and i think
you definitely [ __ ] nailed that on
that series man yeah
i can't i can't what you just said is
exactly
it it is you know one of my favorite
things to do is describe to people like
i grew up in berkeley
from the neighborhood reading comics i
never think i'm gonna be [ __ ] in life
right
i have no expectations of anything good
happening in my life
20 something 30 years later
i'm on the second floor of marvel
building where thanos's glove life-size
glove is there and the real three
iron man suits from beginning to the
most modern one are in the lobby
security buzzes me through this is my
first day of marvel
to my left life side statue of t'challa
to my right as i'm walking glass walls
encasing thor's hammer
ant-man's helmet steve's book right
i make a left now the walls are painted
wall-to-wall
with marvel characters and action scenes
right black panther fighting cap
and there's shells of comic books and
then
steve steve's uh shield
in case in glass each writer's room is
named after a different avenger
i get iron man right i walk into iron
man
and the concept art is laid out on the
walls and by now
after everything i've been through in
hollywood i'm
as cynical as i don't even to this day
feel like i'm part of this industry you
know i'm saying
because of what these people did to me
and
man i got choked up it was hard not to
cry the concept art for sam
with that [ __ ] shield because i was a
kid who grew up on this [ __ ]
and getting to what you're saying
there's no way you can be possessive
over this [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
it is so much bigger than you and it's
been handled so
[ __ ] well by these people you are
lucky to be in here to be part of it
if you're really a fan and so i think
your wheels and the spokes thing
and define it is is a flawless
description of the best you can hope for
um where is uh
here i i know i'm always trying to like
not throw you into a place where you're
like i can't talk about that but
i have we all read that that there's
going to be a captain america
four and then see that look on malcolm's
face like
maybe you did maybe you didn't that's
right
that's true i read somewhere online if
like if that was true
would that writing have started already
first of all i would say this if kevin
hasn't said it
then you don't you cannot assume it's
true
um that's true the rest you can probably
we're talking about the most important
kevin in the world kevin feige
i mean yes kevin there's one kevin in
hollywood oh thanks man
[Laughter]
i literally live behind the hollywood
sign [ __ ]
i'm joking there no you're right though
there's only one kevin that matters so
until he said it it's not
you're saying it's not a truth that's
not real
is uh is there any desire on your part
because i i know there's there's an
appetite for it
um not the least of which among kevin
and i
to tell that young isaiah story to tell
the [ __ ] like let's do it let's do
the indoctrination let's do the
injection let's do the betrayals let's
do all of it
yeah i mean it would but how do you do
it right you know what i'm saying like
how you do like i felt
i felt very comfortable with
how we handled what we have right
you you just gotta it's gotta be the
right person
and then you gotta do it right because
you're basically talking about a tragedy
a true tragedy
at marvel which is different like we
dealt with race we dealt with privilege
we dealt with you know the feeling of
with displaced people and powerlessness
we deal with a lot of big relevant
themes
but i don't think our show
our series was a tragedy and
you know for isaiah there's just there's
no that's just it is you know that's a
tough thing to do
you know what i'm saying but i would
when we when we think about it we think
about like oh to see him in action
but you're right like it's the it's the
titanic we know where the story
eventually ends and it's not
a [ __ ] happy place and just like as
we watched in captain america the first
avenger
he rescues everybody and he's given a
hero's welcome and the third act begins
and [ __ ]
that would not be the case nope
surprisingly you're right
it might be yeah it's it's a
very tough because you have to set up
these
you would have to set up these men so
that you care about them being betrayed
and the whole time you're watching this
it's like watching [ __ ]
dr frankenstein will be like wait what
and now that you don't like it'd be
tough you'd get
you'd probably get a nice teaser where
they send isaiah
after a winter soldier you know what i'm
saying and after that may you in some
very serious waters you know what i'm
saying
right um but if if they ever did
anything with that character
i would hope they called me first you
know what i'm saying
you know because i mean there is the
version of that that's saving private
ryan
right like that movie tom hanks it's a
tragedy for that
for that character like there's joy and
there's triumph and there's spirit
and there's hope and there's all those
things but that [ __ ] dies on a
bridge
spoiler everybody that's what happens in
saving private ryan
you know like it's it's dark darker than
perhaps marvel wants to go but there's
probably a path through it that you
still get to do the valor
and the dream and what happens when the
dream is deferred
but mark do you feel like you do get to
do that like
like when you're really like i read that
book bloods that you know
which are like the the
relentlessness of this country's
relationship with our people
is like i mean you know hey dude you get
to walk point
like at every single moment it's like
you know what i'm saying i
i wonder how you eke out like
when the other soldiers are [ __ ]
being racist and then you're saving them
in the next scene you know what i'm
saying and they're not if i mean
are we being frogs in a real and they're
not learning their lesson
you know what i'm saying like i mean
it's a harsh it's a harsh harsh look
come on man you come and ep that [ __ ]
get paid and make it happen
but yeah i mean i think it's it's you
know it's the 1619 project right it's
look here's an awful story it's a harsh
look but it's true
and therefore it has value i i agree and
you are
correct in that all the research we did
like when you listen when you look at
these great
great black soldiers man what they did
in the face of
what they are doing it for and it wasn't
just world war
ii it wasn't just korea it was vietnam
also you know what i'm saying right now
in the current military
there is they deal with you know signs
of white you know white supremacist
organizations infiltrating them they
and they're still out there fighting it
is true that what sam embodies is that
that i'm a fight anyway
like i i don't you know whether or not
this works this is one shot we got to
take
along with some shots back home along
with some shots over here until
someone finds a way to bring something
truth to what
we've been trying to say for 400 years
you know what i'm saying
um in addition to that the the um
one of the things that i loved that went
into the show
and felt very marvel to me
because the show of course felt very
current finger on the pulse
but classic marvel we got to taste in
the very first
episode with the the notion of uh
you don't get paid to be a superhero
like
real world fallibility which we i don't
i don't think like i know that it hasn't
been explored
specifically like you guys did but i
don't even think like other than peter
talking about like i found a computer in
the garbage on my way home
generally speaking they haven't really
dealt with the
topic at all um when did was that
in the pitch too or did that just come
out later on
yeah i mean the that storyline
was in the picture the bank scene
probably was not because i couldn't be
that specific at the moment
but i knew i knew their family business
i had done some research on black
fishermen
in louisiana and i knew that uh uh their
family was struggling because of what
these banks are doing and driving people
out of business
and and it is funny because that scene
kevin
hit on two different levels right
on one level it was sam was black before
he's the falcon and can't get along
right but then the level like one of the
things that
pulled in some of the executive marvel
is like wait a minute this is a huge
deal if we gonna start talking about
how superheroes make a living like the
volume of notes that came in
just on that and the amount of meetings
are like well how do they what is you
know what i'm saying
like it seems hell is simple to say
he has military contracts right but you
know man
anyone who writes you guys both know
we got all kinds of real convoluted [ __ ]
before you get down to something you
know that simple whatever
that yeah that [ __ ] was a trip like if
that that really
that really touched something for fans
that surprised me like that that
discussions like they
whether they knew it or not they've been
waiting to have that discussion it's
it's after
a decade of these movies it's just comic
book thinking like you know you sit
around as a kid afterwards and
discuss who could do what and like who
could be who it's
in the same like area as like how do
they
get paid and so i i've it definitely
touched a nerve with everybody in a good
way with like i haven't thought about
that i haven't heard it before but it's
enjoyable to hear that it gave marvel
pause as well going wait a second
how do they get paid we've never really
thought about this like one guy's super
rich but the rest of them
who [ __ ] knows all right let's ask
one more question and we gotta let you
go cause we know you're on your way out
it's easy for for an audience and even
you know
professionals to impart intentionality
to [ __ ] that happens all the time
but did you have any idea that zemo
would be
the [ __ ] meme generator that zemo
became like
how do you feel like on set when he's
[ __ ]
pounding it out on the dance floor you i
can't claim
i said we that we knew he was gonna
become
there was gonna be a zemo cut but i will
say this as dailies were coming in
and rough cuts were coming in it was
clear that daniel was [ __ ] dialed
in like he was just he understood
we had described and i don't even know
if that description made it to him
because you know you do so many
revisions
but we described zemo his interaction
with sam and bucky but particularly
bucky
as you know a genius playing with a
broken toy
right and the spirit of that
he took and man i'd send him an email
man i was like man you was just playing
with the scenes and just like
it was like jazz dude it was just like
he was doing whatever he wants and it
all felt natural
and just just so many little details in
a given scene
where zemo was deepening it like it's
yeah you're laughing at it
but but the actor is so [ __ ] present
that it feels like exactly what zemo
would have done you know what i'm saying
so
now i know about the means but i
definitely knew that
he was crushing it i knew he was taking
[ __ ] out the park
it was a tough act to follow
um not just one division on disney plus
but [ __ ]
season two of the mandalorian and it's
safe to say you guys
pun intended spread your [ __ ] wings
man it was
epic absolutely thank you man well
and one last thing just for my own
notification so
as showrunner do you get to go to set
when they're shooting were you there
when they shot all the episodes yeah i
was out there i was out there in the
beginning and then you know i came back
um the the way you know you got kari was
with us in the writers room
yeah and then zoe nate's
mini me right um is on set with them
and we just we're able to work remotely
on rewrites because
the continuity is completely [ __ ]
intact
that's the genius of their system that
we are all one hub
you know what i'm saying so me
personally kevin
after many i you know i'm not a dude who
loves set anymore i am
i prefer if it can be done from far away
you know
i prefer to do that when did when did
set die for you was it you're an empire
i'm not going to tell you but
you circumspect man you but it's so wild
to me because you
like in 2000 you wrote your first spec
it's 2021
and somewhere in between there you got
to the place already in your career
where you're like i hate going to set
it's yeah that's another episode man
like if
it is when to relate listen like the
relationship with anthony
no offense i've had an amazing
relationship with creative relationships
with actors right
yeah yeah but the connection with
anthony was just special you know what
i'm saying like
do you you know that tension dude when
actors have an
issue with something and you're like oh
[ __ ] you know they're gonna come for me
there was never any of that with him we
was
we was creatively in tune with each
other
and easy all the way through this thing
and so part of it is i don't know if i
really needed to be in second i could be
on the phone with him
for two or three hours talking about a
scene
and get it done that way but it's the
opposite of that sometimes too
sometimes there's no respect and there's
no love
and you got to be there and with a
[ __ ] who if they decide not to
step out their trailer you know i'm
saying your whole shit's going to shut
down and you don't want to be the one
who calls that
so you're eating [ __ ] um so it's just a
thing like
you know i love i gotta admit the last
few
shows everyone's been [ __ ] amazing
like you know i work with my wife on her
show
with octavia who is if the prototype
of genius and just professional awesome
human being on set her
so maybe it's coming back to me but i
got old school traumas from years past
but anthony was a dream that's the best
relationship i ever had with an actor
um it shows in the work man you got
beautiful workout he's a wonderful
always has been a wonderful actor but
man oh man he
he rose he's special bro yeah he became
he took it to another level with this
project um
we loved it man i love that it means a
lot man you know i know y'all y'all are
serious about
about your stuff about your your drama
so i i really appreciate it and uh and i
i appreciate y'all having me for sure
man it's it's something special that
your first script got shaved out the
black dude yeah and then now
all circles back around like we let's
put a black dude in this white [ __ ]
that's right nah i not thought about it
like that but yeah that's
that's pretty poetic mark it all comes
around man
yeah all right y'all all right good
thank you welcome everyone give it up
for malcolm
yeah late y'all be easy
um i i love tim he's my kind of offender
um i'm sure there's some part of me that
thinks that the marvel publicists were
like
why does he have to curse so much like
that i know that like i'm normally that
guy
like it was so refreshing to be like is
that what it sounds like like when
somebody's just
incredibly refreshingly frank and like
doesn't kind of blow smoke about the
business
um well he's that there's a there's a
story that should inspire you kids
he got his first taste of success 20
years ago
and it took 20 [ __ ] years for him to
catch up to this level of success um
patience patience and be true to
yourself apparently as well and keep
working it
and and and be open to the new scenarios
you know like i'm talking about like i'm
not sure if i was ready to be a staff
writer on empire
he's like all right gotta surrender to
it gotta learn how to do it and then
eventually take it
over and it seems like for him talking
winter soldier is the same thing
like all right i'm resisting this this
system and this environment
and then i gotta surrender to it and
understand it and then
that way we can all succeed um it makes
me wanna watch the show again
yeah yeah and it also makes me
wanna theorize who that actor who made
him hate set was
but i have my ideas i have my theories
you think so ah
yeah next time baby oh
oh really
i think i think i think i know what
you're talking about yeah
um yeah it's he's he's just so [ __ ]
awesome because most people you know are
like uh
oh it was great everything's great and
like you know it was great
but he was just like this sucked outside
people suck
i love that kind of reel uh okay
[ __ ] man uh that was good i wish yeah i
wish we had more he had some [ __ ] to do
so we only had him for a little window
but
god in that time he gave [ __ ] quality
and i also love
when we get an insight into how the
sausage is made
particularly the sausage that we love to
consume oh so much
um hearing like the the
inside the nitty-gritty hearing that
detail about
the execs who don't have multiple
projects but only one that they follow
from [ __ ] cradle to grave
like that's that don't happen anywhere
else
no like most studios have two kinds of
execs they have development execs
who work on the scripts and stuff and
then current execs who cover shows that
are in production already on the air
and they all have lots of [ __ ] to do so
nobody's following the show from
beginning to end
nobody's solely focused on one show
during that process
and so to get that level of attention
you know it's yeah like if
if you're concerned about an executive
is that they don't understand the
material and they can't give the time
and the effort to it
marvel seems to have absolved that
concern
which is yeah no they know as much about
it as you do they're an active member
of the storytelling team and so they
you know to malcolm's point like good
ideas win and
uh and if they have good ideas then
invite him in
um he was great
i feel you know i feel i've i feel like
like this is what like a wham bam thank
you man feels like
you know what i'm saying he came in
rocked our worlds and he's [ __ ] gone
it's like where
who was that masked man did he leave
some money on the counter
that interview was so good i you know
what i need a
a cbd smoke mark really a
clove no cloves are illegal i've
come to find out um yeah who knew
so what instead is this is a non-thc
non-marijuana hemp cbd infused
pre-roll for the good take your word for
it
for yes in case mark zuckerberg was
curious this is not
marijuana this is just a cbd pre-roll
cigarette
and i think after that in intense real
interview like where i just feel like we
got thoroughly [ __ ] well
i think i deserve a smoke excellent
you've earned it
you hit three states today
tell me about it um all right well [ __ ]
the guest is gone so that machine's
those cbd smokes hit hard they really do
uh with our guests gone folks that leads
us into
the uh only next part the only part of
the show that uh
we could possibly go to next which is
the heart the girth of the show
if what we just had was the shiny helmet
this is the
long thick ass veiny neck
of the show that is the news mr mark
bernardin
who's right over there over there over
there there he is
he is an old news hound kid you didn't
know that about him did you
you thought he was just a great writer
no he's a news writer as well at one
point man but he left that world behind
he abandoned it he walked away from it
but it still calls to him every once in
a while he'll get a call in the middle
of the night and they're like can you
hear
break some hard news for us mark like
you did back in the old days
and he'll go out and do it and then
periodically he throws a little news
our way as well man a little secondhand
news mr mark bernardin
is now here gonna give you the news mark
what's the news
uh well the news the the biggest news
this week
at least it felt like the biggest news
to me at any rate
was uh was the trailer that marvel had
dropped
for the go back to the movies everybody
just please go see some stuff
like let's get smile and stan lee to
help talk you through the reasons why
we should all go to the theater and also
let's tell you
what you'll be seeing once you return to
the theater
and in doing so they revealed some stuff
that we knew
like we knew they were making a turtles
movie we hadn't seen any footage from it
so now we got our first look at the
eternals movie
we knew they were making black panther 2
we did not know that would be called
wakanda forever which is the perfect
name for black panther 2.
um we knew there was a captain marvel
too but we didn't know that it was
the marvels and now it will somehow wrap
its arms around the fact that we now
have three
characters who have some connection to
captain marvel
um spectrum and ms marvel and the
titular captain marvel
um we also separately learned that loki
um would be shifting from
sundays right fridays sundays whatever
the day yeah
to wednesdays um and it'll be premiering
on june 9th instead of june 11.
um all of which is [ __ ] awesome like
it's all just
glittery gold that was delivered unto us
um the best part of that trailer other
than the
uh glimpse um at
you know the eternals the
them using the number four [ __ ] like
that
of course is it opened with stan's
uh voice-over and
you know the voice-over was so
pitch-perfect
you forgot for a second that he's not
here anymore
it seemed like it was recorded just for
that [ __ ] spot
but jim mclaughlin um i believe is
responsible for that
chunk of text that stan read um
yeah we gotta get more details on that
let me see if
he had written to me he had texted me
let me see if i could pull it up
but we were talking you know i was like
oh that trailer and he was like uh
he said i [ __ ] you not i wrote the stand
bit for stan
in 2017.
and i said you wrote it he said yup
crazy story remind me to tell you
sometime
well remind him remind him
hey bamf boy get in here and get us jim
mclaughlin
and while you're at it rustle up victor
garber as well
a banff boy
banff
sounded so defeated bam if you keep
calling him banff boy that's exactly
he's dobbing the house off at this point
um how did you start watching uh the bad
batch
i did watch bad match so before we dive
into the news
since you are a star wars bonafide star
wars man
who owns a bonafide star wars bar an
intergalactic space cantina you mean my
bad my bad yes
a faceport themed bar brand agnostic
uh you will be our our designated bad
batcher
so let's hear it how was it compared
with dc
that is such a big [ __ ] star wars fan
and a lot of people think i am because
of the movies and [ __ ] but jc
knows all the extended universe [ __ ] and
whatnot and whatnot so
you don't have to do ketchup for any of
these
projects or cartoons you'd watch them
correct
yeah and i'll i'm going to say something
controversial here i'm going to go where
malcolm wouldn't go controversial is uh
i may have liked bad batch more than
mandalorian are you [ __ ] at one episode
of the bad match
two well we got two we got a 71 minute
episode and then we got a 22 minute
episode on
friday so we got a a movie's worth we
got
four episodes essentially of mandalorian
in the first week of bad batch in terms
of time
and uh to me like i'm a
i'm a new hope guy i'm a return of the
jedi guy i'm not like the empire strikes
back guy
and this had the the swashbuckling
and the fun and the humor i felt
that was more a new hope than empire
strikes back whereas i feel like the
mandalorian kind of picks up
totally where the empire strikes back
finished
this felt like like uh
great adventure star wars to me
which i i really loved um
the uh who who who's in charge
of so dave filoni is the creator kind of
overseer um but they've got a new guy
whose name i'm spacing on um
that has kind of come up through the
system
uh and the bad felony co-wrote
the first episode the first episode yeah
i mean it's definitely like
his offspring it's it's his idea
um and he just has another guy he's like
feigy
i think for the the star wars animation
now and
he's kind of let his children go and run
um
and it opens with the clone wars logo
that burns up into a bad batch logo so
you
know it's going to be a direct sequel to
the clone wars
and then you get uh
like right off the bat i know one of the
things we've talked about is like when
is this show gonna take place
it takes place concurrently with
episode three so you get to see
palpatine's speech from episode three
from like
different planets and different you know
clone commanders it's pretty cool
uh the way that they kind of integrate
it into
the star wars we've known forever and
then kind of take it in a totally new
direction
any new characters um
we have the new the big new character is
a character named omega
who is a young uh kind of like
adolescent
female um who is
uh we don't know much about her she's
never been off camino
so you get to see her experience what
stars look like for the first time or
put her hands down in dirt which is kind
of fun to explore like oh this is
somebody who's been on a
on a metal box in the middle of an ocean
her whole life
um but i think the idea being that uh
she is a f a faulty clone just like the
bad batch guys are
um which is also kind of a cool thing
uh i know on this show mark has talked a
lot about how star wars is kind of about
family where you know the
the prequel trilogy you have kind of
obi-wan and anakin and it's a
kind of a brotherly family relationship
there
and then luke and vader in the original
trilogy
uh and then in the mandalorian it's uh
mando and grogu so you're getting kind
of a different
another new kind of look on that with
the bad batch these
a-team-like mercenaries
who are trying to figure out their place
in the world and now they're raising a
kid
while they're trying to you know they've
been programmed to be these people
uh the the galaxy has changed and now
they're figuring out how to navigate
that
on their own but also they have a a kid
that they're raising
alongside it it's almost like uh
like full house like you've got danny
tanner
is hunter and then you've got like the
two
two or three weird uncles they all live
in a spaceship
everywhere you look everywhere
the force is around it's all around
can i tell you my theory about omega jc
and
i haven't seen the second episode so i
don't know if they've revealed this or
not
i don't know if this is a thing that
they're holding on to or will ever
answer
but my theory is that omega is a clone
of moff tarkin that has gone
somewhat awry and so and and and tarkin
doesn't want her which is why she's sort
of banging around this [ __ ] space
station she's faulty because
maybe it was supposed to be a he turned
it to be a she whatever that is
um that's my theory which
will fuel all kinds of [ __ ]
pieces and identities and all that stuff
here's my theory i haven't even watched
the show yeah
that girl is boba fett's sister
why not i mean it would be like
technically speaking
right because if they're if they're
clones then it would be
boba's sister and they'd be yeah
right around the same age so
my initial thought was that it was a
clone of palpatine
like the first failed kind of clone of
palpatine
but i don't know haven't they done that
storyline already too much
i was also going to say i think this is
the most interesting time in the star
wars galaxy
in that you're watching the new republic
or the
old republic is gone this is the
the birth of the time in star wars that
we all
love and you get to see that a little
bit in these these episodes
in that it's uh
like in the mandalorian you're watching
and they're still trying to figure out
like what
currency i don't want to use imperial
credits well imperial credits still work
what about new republic credits that
doesn't work in in
bad batch it's like no it's imperial
credits end of discussion
so they got to lace in kind of
very subtly how quickly the kind of
uh military military
the i'm not going to get that word out
right now it's been a long day
like the fascists take over extremely
quickly in this episode meaning
uh within days of
palpatine declaring himself empire
emperor
it's it's everywhere they've got troops
everywhere everybody's got a register
everybody's got to get a number
everybody this is the new money throw
your old money away
exchange your old money five years after
the rebellion killed palpatine it's
still flandering all over the place
which i think is also
kind of a an interesting thing that
they're they're playing with
uh kind of in the background which i
really enjoyed
in the chat they want you to bring up
chain codes
oh ch chain codes it's uh
everybody needs to register
essentially for an id number or a social
security number
which is if they want to travel if they
want to be on an imperial controlled
planet
they need to register um which you know
is is analogous to uh
you know what we've seen tons of times
on
on our uh you know in real life um i
mean i think the parallels
to you know nazism are
very clear in the original star wars
trilogy and i
they're building up to that and and
expanding on that
with uh with details in this for sure
um and it's i i also like it is kind of
like it's kind of
like yin to the yang of mandalorian
where it's almost like you're getting
the same
kind of story but set at opposite ends
of uh of
this governmental system which i thought
was was
uh kind of fun how many episodes is it
gonna be
16 episodes and we got we're two in
the [ __ ] kind of like crazy ass old
school number is that
who does 16 nobody i mean i guess they
can do whatever they want the
they're still using all the animation
style and everything
is very clone wars so they're not
reinventing the wheel with new computer
model like they're not building stuff
from scratch they have
seven eight years of clone wars
foundation that they're building off of
so i think they can probably take that
extra
scratch and give us 16 episodes instead
of the disney plus 8 or 10.
um all right i dug it
you uh you heard it here kids banff
boys exclusive and did you hear
that chat mark dug it
i did dig it mark likes it everybody
oh my yeah i i guess we [ __ ] just
sped
past that there should be some sort of
bell that we ring when mark
stinks for everybody
uh you liked episode one mark i did i
did i didn't see the second one yet
but i mean the animation is great you
know even and even though i'm
not nearly the clone wars completest as
a as a jc might be i knew enough to know
what was happening
i knew enough to to know that when you
heard the order 66 be
put out that like what that meant and
and the fact that our guys were not
obeying it and what that means
um you know i think they've always done
a very masterful job at
making the same person sound different
enough to be
five separate characters um
and i did find it kind of emotional
towards the end of it there's betrayal
there's embracing there's
you know sort of parental desires and
urges and and
you know what it means to be atypical in
a
sea of people who are the same i think
it's always a really interesting story
so now i'm on board well done ken
there it is two votes two up votes
from uh our fat man beyond panel
of two bad batch um all right
to the news mark what's going on in the
news uh we were talking about
uh i'm talking about the marvel rundown
of steph marvel trailer
and uh stan's voice in it and stuff i'm
trying to think what
what i liked best
i mean i loved hearing the old man's
voice again like i cried the first time
i saw that trailer i was like oh
um you know they showed us
more shang chi but we'd already seen
some shang qi
the the eternals piece
looked interesting like big old wide
shots out in nature and [ __ ]
there was that story that broke um that
uh
that you know kevin feige when
presenting eternals
to i guess members of the disney you
know high
counselor or whatever you know had to
explain to them
as was explained to him they're like
we did that all in camera like there's
no cg on some of those shots it's
literally just
chloe saying i want to shoot on a beach
and let me show you what happens when a
really talented dp
can get you know the time and the space
to make art
and like yeah we don't need to wrestle
dazzle it like we can make it
actually the way they used to make
movies for a hundred years which is
we're going to a placement
hey listen don't [ __ ]
like tell kevin foggy stories like that
you know we wanna we wanna come on we
want more marvel guests
and you might want to work there one day
so i didn't mind
for the record kids nothing kevin feige
does is wrong
it's all good and it's all great uh
it did look great it did yeah i mean the
the eternal stuff looks really strong
never mind i was gonna say a thing about
a thing but i'm not gonna because to
your point
at some point i would like to work for
marvel
oh is a critical thing well it was just
remember like
just after that broke there was a a big
banner on imdb
of like the eternals cast but like
yeah what was why did you sense mark
sent me this image
of the eternals cast that was at the top
of imdb
and he said like can you believe it or
something and i didn't quite understand
if it was like you objecting to the
artwork or
i said is it that you know because it
was basically
the dude from game of thrones rob stark
right up front with his arms out spread
like this
and all the multicultural charac or
multiculty as malcolm just taught us the
word
um standing behind him and i was like
what is it that the white man is putting
everyone back
what was it it was it was the weird kind
of
photo shopping like it was it felt like
an unfinished piece of art
so it was the quality of the picture
like this feels like [ __ ] action
figure artwork or something
yeah feels like for your first big giant
amazing still photos of the eternals in
costume
it would have been i don't know a little
better
but hey you're neither here nor there
i'm gonna get you a [ __ ]
job and you just i know man i know that
goddamn grave
um let's talk about a marvel
thing that's not a marvel thing but is a
marvel thing
um the trailer for venom
ii uh what is it there will be carnage
no there will be carnage
there will be carnage um dropped this
morning
yeah and uh you know look
first venom i didn't see in theaters i
saw at home video
and i [ __ ] enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it
i was like wow
who knew it was like he's got it's got a
sense of humor to it
that was directed by ruben fleischer uh
this new one directed
by precious himself andy [ __ ] circus
right indeed
he had done one of those jungle book
movies the one that played on
netflix uh but we all know him from like
[ __ ] gollum [ __ ] planet of the
apes [ __ ] alfred coming up this guy
wears a lot of hats
he does he's a he's a multi-hyphenate
you truly he's [ __ ] a circus life for
me
hi doodle dvd as they say so uh the
trailer
was [ __ ] fun the one that they
dropped today and we got our first look
well our second look at cletus cassidy
first time we saw him with a
raggedy ann and andy frightwig at the
end of first venom but
now they've given them more of a shorter
crop due and stuff
and we got our first look at the
cinematic carnage
with you know which is basically for
those who don't follow that closely
thinner red venom what he looks like
the red vine to uh yes to
uh fat
glad you licorice that when i was like
where are we going with this man
it was just a twizzler thing don't piss
those people off
um so the trailer looks uh [ __ ] good
and fun it didn't see any
no like uh i guess the bad guy is
carnage
so there's your [ __ ] villain [ __ ]
woody harrelson chewing the scenery
and uh what's his name [ __ ] uh tom
uh i'm marty just [ __ ]
chewing the scenery yet again man in
that good way like uh
he's also the voice of venom isn't he
yes
yeah i'm sure it's pitch shifted and
altered and
tweaked within an inch of its life but i
think he's doing both of those things
um he seems to be having a good time i
look forward to it
you know i would have liked to have seen
a lot more carnage but i'm gonna see
that when i see the movie i'm sure
i'm sure trailer number two will give
you more of it and then the movie will
give you all of it
wow what uh but i also found myself for
the rest of the day
[ __ ] listening to one
alone good use of music what'd you think
of the trailer
um i feel about the trailer the same way
i kind of felt about the first movie
which was okay i guess we're doing this
now
like i i have no attachment to venom as
a character he was never i mean i
remember when the symbiote gets
introduced in secret wars and when it
becomes a whole thing
in in spider-man books but like
it was never a thing i needed more of
personally and
the first movie is just like that [ __ ]
crazy in ways that i could not have
expected a movie to be
um and it feels like this trailer was
like oh yeah
hold my beer we'll be more batshit crazy
and uh and you know
threaten to eat the nice chinese lady
who owns the bodega down the street
a lot um you know i i feel like
when it arrives on on home viewing
i will happily tune in um but i it's not
a
i don't think i'm running out to the
theater to go see it
is that right you want yeah i didn't i
didn't go out to see the first one in
theater and then when i watched it at
home i was like oh i would have actually
enjoyed this
so i will actually go see this one
uh in a theater i'm you know i'm i'm not
i wasn't one of those people that's like
i want the world to open man i'm [ __ ]
tired of this [ __ ] i was like i get it
we all gotta
hide from the germ um but you know
i've had my double shots now for a while
and and the numbers here in california
keep [ __ ]
dropping there's a day last week where
nobody died from [ __ ] covet and stuff
so looks like we're getting back to that
place where the world is gonna start
opening up more and more and i'll be
honest with you like
six months ago i couldn't conceive of
going to sit in the movie theater unless
it was like a private rented theater
like money bags bernardin does every
once in a while and [ __ ] when he goes
all robert kirkman
[ __ ] rents out a whole goddamn movie
theater for him and his wife so they can
[ __ ] make out and [ __ ] and watch the
movies well we all can't beat kirkman i
mean i hear he's buying the arc lights
all of them just for him makes sense
[ __ ] sense pocket change for garlic
come on um
but uh i find myself like
you know i'll just wear a mask and
i'm i'm ready i'm ready to go to the
movies again that marvel trailer did
kind of psyched me up and i'm like yeah
yeah [ __ ] good movies are worth
risking my life for yeah i'm gonna do it
[Music]
um all right so uh what other what other
news can we
talk about um warner brothers
um working with
j.j abrams and ta-nehisi coates a big
story broken the hollywood reporter kind
of
digging into precisely what version
of uh the man of steel they are going to
present
yeah i mean we we missed that story that
was a huge [ __ ] story when did that
happen
um that happened i want to say it was
like tuesday or wednesday of last week
so the story kids of course everybody
watching the show already knows but
i don't i think as the hollywood
reporter announced that like warner
brothers is
doing black superman right
which you know i feel like we kind of
thought was
a real thing that was happening but the
new wrinkle is because there's different
ways to go there's there's kal-el the
traditional version of superman that
we've had
there's clark kent correct
there's
like years ago like
what an interesting take it would be if
it was clark kent
to have this boy in kansas raised by
you know this white family maybe and
he's a black kid
like it just makes that version
of superman's story you know because a
lot of people have been like why does it
have to be clark kent
let it be calvin ellis or let it be
you know the other one and stuff um i do
feel like i go either way i'm happy with
whichever version they give us
but based on the discussion we had years
ago like i always thought that would be
kind of cool to be like how how does
clark kent's story change
you know he's already treated like a
kind of outcast
in a lot of the versions of the stories
we've seen
and he looks like everybody else it adds
like another real world wrinkle to it if
like people like clark's weird and he's
also like the only black kid in this
kansas school
so that i mean that's ripe with
storytelling potential
um i do understand when people are like
i don't need it to be clark kent i'll
take
you know just like michael jordan
himself has said like
i don't know why he would do clark kent
they already have calvin else he showed
off a very [ __ ] like comic book savvy
amount
of knowledge about you know beyond just
the saying superman anybody could be
like clark kent superman but he went
deep with the other two as well
so i get the two schools of thought you
know the people who are like
oh that'd be [ __ ] amazing if it was a
clark kent
and the people who were like i think
it's stupid if it's
clark kent i'm happy either way
whichever
version they give us i'm down for but
what i read between the lines of all
these stories
and tell me if i'm wrong is michael
jordan is going to be playing
whoever the character is um
not according to him because he's he was
quoted at the top of this hollywood
hollywood reporter piece saying he
interviewed when his uh
amazon movie without remorse was coming
out
and he you know somebody asked him it's
like well you know clearly they're
talking about
you know wanting you to play superman
he's like no that's not for me i will
happily just watch
when it makes it to the theater now
maybe that's a marvel style
like i'm not doing it until i'm doing it
or yeah because he's like you know what
i didn't go into a theater it's going
hbo max
or something like that but didn't he
like i i remember him talking about
wanting to do it like
about six months to a year ago it
preceded all this
jj chatter or maybe not even a year ago
about
six months like the jj deal happened and
then another story that kind of broke
out was
i thought maybe i'm crazy michael jordan
wanting to play or them with a studio
interested in him playing
superman and now it feels like this
another story to solidify
what might have been rumor i don't know
what are your thoughts
yeah i mean i i i feel the same way you
feel which is
you know i honestly don't care which
version of superman they do
there's a hundred percent an interesting
version of kal-el
being a person of color landing in
kansas in 1958 or whatever
um and and for all of those social
wrinkles that you get to add to what is
already a story about an adopted kid
who's an outsider
you're just sort of bolstering both of
those sort of elements
um and then what it means similar to the
story that you know
what we're talking to to malcolm about
before what it means to be that
character with that much
power in a world that would probably be
afraid of him for any number of reasons
that don't even include him being an
alien
um and then what is your responsibility
towards these people what is your
perspective towards your own power
in a place where you know you're
watching atrocities being committed
and you have the capacity to fix them
but potentially not the responsibility
to do so i think all that's really
interesting
that said i don't know a ton about
calvin ellis or valzad
but i'm sure there are legit stories to
be told in that angle too
you know what happens is nobody talking
about
milestones superman oh icon and rocket
hardware icon i mean i think they're
they're they're definitely doing a
static shock live-action movie
um and that's probably um
a bit of a shoehorn into the rest of the
milestone universe
and so yeah maybe there's some version
where that's part of a long game
um the collision of all those universes
and if dc
you know whatever they're calling their
movie initiative at this point
is about anything it's about multiverses
and so there's 100
in the world in which post flashpoint
you are collapsing
lots of these multiverses into the same
thing or at the very least getting to
visit
a bunch of them um the milestone the
dakotaverse absolutely
potentially one of them um but yeah i
mean i'm i'm here for michael b jordan
if he wants to play
[ __ ] superman or valzad or calvin
ellis
or like he said i just want to watch it
you know and lend some support behind it
but you know and the other part of the
story is that jj will probably not be
directing
this superman movie um he won't be
he won't be i think that he feels warner
brothers feels all part is concerned
feel
that if you're gonna do the black
superman movie you should probably have
a director of color
um to get behind the lens on that and so
now there's the
the hot race for which black person
is going to direct black superman and
blade which
currently does not have a director um
blade didn't have a presence in that
trailer did it
it did not it did not um
you know which i don't know if it's a
matter of they don't have the confidence
in it which i don't think is the case
because i just think they
have nothing for it that maybe it's
phase five
yeah you know i think that they're
they're a far there are ways away
from having very much um to say about
blade
and for as important to character as
blade is to
you know the people to the fans um it
might not be as important
to the mcu as fantastic four is and so
they continue to kind of plant a flag
reminding you that fantastic four is
coming
as am i just a thought of a
mighty controlled fantastic four oh my
god think about how good that can be
remember when they brought a spider-man
back and how good it was
and like oh my god they didn't bother to
tell us his origin story anymore they
just dove in
and you got [ __ ] tom holland and [ __ ]
like
they could do me that way with fantastic
four i don't need no origin and [ __ ] i
bet you they do an origin
they probably will i think because you
know it's it's a
it's a series of characters and it's a
franchise
that people all have some familiarity
with but very little knowledge of
and so i think you need to reintroduce
those characters back to the mainstream
in a way you don't have to with
spider-man it's like oh yeah it's
[ __ ] spider-man we've just had four
origin stories in the last 10 years you
know who that guy is
uh what's the next story uh the next
story is
you know in the in the ongoing saga
of uh joss whedon v um
the good people of hollywood slash
common sense
um do you see this [ __ ] is this the gal
gadot
this is the gagadot story holy crap like
you know we anyone who watches this show
probably of course
knows and remembers that uh
ray fisher you know [ __ ] made his
twitter statements and and and started
saying his
you know joss whedon is not a good guy
and and harassed people or whatever put
that out there
and people like beat it back and whatnot
and then
gal gadot one day just like jason momoa
co-signed it
and said like you know i hear
ray let him speak his truth or whatever
the [ __ ]
and there had been a rumor that gal
gadot had gotten into
like a little something with joss whedon
on set
and then that started popping up in the
press
people talking about it but then gal
gadot didn't say anything about it then
gal gadot did say something about it
but very little but seemed to confirm
that there was
something and now just this week gal
gadot was on israeli tv and tell him
what she did mark
um she said it wasn't a very long
statement
but it was i had my issues with josh and
i handled it
he threatened my career and said that if
i do something he will make sure my
career was miserable
and i took care of it on the spot gadot
said
um i you know what man like
sometimes i i want how do i say this
without
sounding whatever hold on i'm going to
try to phrase it sometimes i wonder
if i should have done a little bit more
with my career
you know what i'm saying instead of just
kevin smith over
and over and over and over again
um you know and like with with the
advent and success the last 10 years
plus of
superhero comic book movies particularly
as a guy who was always into
this [ __ ] long you know before [ __ ]
the business took
notice of it you know one could
make the assertion that like he why
isn't he making one of those [ __ ]
movies and as i've said many times that
i'm just not really
those movies are beyond my talent
capability and
they take a long time and there are
plenty of very talented people who are
willing to make those movies
ain't nobody wants to make a kevin smith
movie except kevin smith so forth and so
on
um but every once in a while mark in
three small hours in the morning yes i'm
alone
and there's no streaming and no audience
and and nobody to entertain and when i'm
just alone
with my thoughts and having a puff of a
cbd
infused hemp only cigarette facebook
sometimes i say to myself
i wonder what it'd be like to be
x y or z person
and over the course of my career
i have had this thought and i i'm not
somebody who ever
watched buffy i never watched firefly
um but i saw joss's two avengers movies
and stuff
but there have definitely been moments
in my career
where i was like i wonder what it'd be
like
to be joss whedon like instead of me
instead of just doing what i do what
would it be like to be that
universally beloved um
i don't i don't wonder that anymore mark
that question has been answered
something like
success you know i'm not gonna blanket
everybody but like
you know who says something like that
i like i'm just i always try to put it
into like
my mindset and i i can't like there's no
circumstances under which i'd be telling
somebody you'll never
lunch in this town again or [ __ ]
threatening their
[ __ ] career number one that is
repugnant to me it's an anathema to
a creative community to will somebody or
threaten
somebody's creativity you know people
like that i
like anybody that [ __ ] makes it this
much harder
for somebody to go have fun at this job
to make and pretend
and potentially ruins it for that person
that they've
you know [ __ ] around with like those are
some of the worst [ __ ] people in this
business
now good thing gal gadot you know it
didn't ruin her where she's like i'm
leaving this business
but there are a lot of other people
along the way and i'm not saying and i
know joss whedon's done this but
there's a you know a litter of bodies in
this town of
people who are not even in this town
people have been chased out of this town
by people who say [ __ ] like that like
that just blows my mind generally you
know i'm always kind of like oh well
i'll stay out of this and i have no
opinion but like
come on man like [ __ ] you can't say
stupid [ __ ] like you know i'll [ __ ]
ruin you in this business
like what what do you what do you think
this is an episode of [ __ ] dynasty
like it's just such a weird thing man so
she flat out said that it happened
and you know it's i don't know maybe
like you know when you have a movie that
makes a billion dollars and the whole
world
says you're great like maybe you get
so full of yourself that you feel like
you can say something like
to gal gadot who i've never met but
seems like a
[ __ ] incredibly sweet person and mind
you wasn't this justice league shoot
after wonder woman so she's already like
a [ __ ] huge star right
like do you know the [ __ ] hoots but
it takes to say to some
giant billion dollar grosser like
somebody who's been the face of a movie
that has made a billion [ __ ] dollars
the character the titular character pun
intended no pun intended
wonder woman herself and you're gonna be
like
i can i'll ruin you in this town i'll
like
not to mention he was the second
director on this movie
it it like it just uh to me it's just
it's
baffling but like i
there was a part of me that like when
she said oh there were things and blah
blah blah but
i was like it couldn't have been there's
like i was like there's no way he
because i'd heard around the halls that
he threatened her
career not threatened her physically but
was like literally like [ __ ]
i can ruin you in this business and i
was like there's no [ __ ] way
that's like something out of a 30s
hollywood movie or something like that
um and then i saw like a kind of
confirmation a few months ago in the
press where i was like well he maybe he
did say something and again i don't know
this guy or anything but i just
can't imagine anybody like you got to be
like
you know just have an ounce of
strategic [ __ ] interest in your own
career
to not [ __ ] shoot yourself in the
foot or something like that
but hearing this now like when she you
know i couldn't
obviously i don't speak what israeli or
hebrew or something so i
i heard her say it but i had to read the
translation
and in reading the translation i was
just like
he literally did the rumors were
absolutely true
and she just as the only other party who
could [ __ ]
confirm or deny it she flat out
confirmed what
had been rumored for a long time that he
threatened her [ __ ] future like that
blows my mind i don't even think
like could a spielberg get away with
that
like quentin tarantino like is there
such a thing as a
a director that like i would believe
that if the director said that to me
like if i could
joss whedon said that's me i'd be like
yeah
all right firefly keep buzzing [ __ ]
you're right
but like what what must have happened
to get to that [ __ ] point right like
what was it what was the thing he said
to do do you think it was the flash
falling on her
bit um it very well could have been
because there was a rumor
that they had a body double for that but
that reason
exactly yeah i mean it's got to be i
mean that what they've said or right or
at least what gal
is i don't know if she said it or
somebody
around her said it was that um it was
about protecting the integrity of her
character like
she thought he was taking her character
in a weird direction
uh a weird too aggressive direction
after
the wonder woman performance of the
movie itself
but it's maybe it could be not just like
as vague as like i didn't like the
direction he was taking the character
but it could be
that specific moment or it could be
it could be things that we've never even
seen you know could be a thing that she
flat out refused to do and didn't make
the movie because she wouldn't do it
i mean like again this is america's
sweetheart man
like this is the world sweetheart i know
it's literally wonder woman and you're
gonna be like
you'll never eat lunch in this town
again that's that's he didn't say that
kids i keep repeating that just because
that's a
title of an 80s book that was an old
[ __ ] like hollywood exec
kind of threat what did he say exactly
do you have it right there um
i mean according she said he said what
she said was
um he threatened my career and said that
if i do something he will make sure my
career is miserable
and i took care of it on the spot
that's like that's so [ __ ] up to me
yeah i mean it's and i've been in this
business 27 years man and like
you think at a certain point like if you
haven't seen it all
you've at least heard it all and
that just like you gotta be you gotta
really believe in yourself in a big bad
way to be like hey
wonder woman i'm the [ __ ] boss here
not to mention like you know i don't
know was it wasn't he like
isn't he like a mr feminist or something
like that like why is it i mean
that that was that's part of the the
issue
the the fact that for so long in his
career
he uh he was able to drape himself in
the virtuous armor
of a a feminist of a a
a man who told women stories who told
stories of women with agency and with
power
and you know and that's a thing that
sort of followed him throughout his
career
and which he absolutely embraced you
know
what man like not for nothing but like
like i'm a i've worked with
tough talent and sometimes i've worked
with talent that you know it was tough
but you'll never know it like i've never
shared it
and then i've worked with talent that
was so tough i couldn't help but [ __ ]
share it a lot of the case of like bruce
willis and stuff like that
um you know it's a risk when you
tell those tales out of school because
uh that's
what they call biting the hand that
feeds
and so there's you know like a [ __ ]
chance
of blowback or whatever the [ __ ] um
in this instance i personally
i feel like he
fear for his own career longevity
like would have prevented him from
going going at her let alone threatening
her you know what i'm saying like
again you're this like you pointed out
you're the second director
you're not even like this is my [ __ ]
vision you're the guy doing like pickups
and you're gonna fight with one of this
but i mean if you follow that trajectory
though if you follow the trajectory from
i was a you know i wrote the first draft
of
speed i did rewrites on toy story while
i was on staff at roseanne
and then i got buffy and then i get
angel
and then firefly and then i get
um i get to make this firefly movie and
then from that i get avengers and then
avengers 2
and suddenly my movies have grossed five
or six billion dollars
and then warner brothers comes to me to
rescue their failing
um floundering justice league movie so
clearly they need me more than i need
them
and so i'm doing them a favor and so i
have to
you know it's my way or the highway i
don't necessarily want to be here but
you've asked me to do this and so i'm
doing it and so that gives me a sense of
control and power
that's emboldened by the fact that i'm
on this
meteoric career run um all of which
feeds an ego you know and it seems as if
especially in in hollywood but
as is ever you know power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
so he felt like he was untouchable and
that
he wanted what he wanted and how dare
this actress you know not give it to me
you know and whether that extends as ray
fisher
claims to him as well um
it's telling that he did not have issues
like this with jason mamoa
as far as we know or ben affleck as far
as we know
or henry cavill as far as we know also
i don't know if it was in this piece or
another piece but somewhere she
indicated
a gal indicated that she wasn't
on set with rey
and jason like you know they all
shot separately i guess and so
she i guess she wasn't there when like
his he was doing his [ __ ] with with ray
and she was kind of almost i don't know
i'm now putting words in it but she
wasn't it wasn't like a main unit where
everybody was around
right this happened um
the uh yeah it's just nuts
what happens next you think i mean i
we we're we're in a time of
accountability
um you know if we look at a what began
with
you know sort of kevin spacey and harvey
weinstein and bill cosby
and now it's kind of trickled you know
made its way through hollywood and now
we're also having a conversation about
scott rudin
who apparently had been a nightmare for
decades in hollywood
um doing things that if not downright
cruel and unethical
uh may or may not have been illegal from
a
simple assault and battery perspective
um
you know what happens to that guy you
know what what and how does hollywood
treat people
for whom they have a vested financial
interest compared to people for whom
action would be the right thing um and
that's that is always the crux how
useful are you in hollywood
will sort of dictate how hollywood
treats your infidelities and discretions
and so forth and so on
so is josh whedon somebody that
hollywood wants to have stuff
more business with then if so he will do
the thing that hollywood has always done
which is
you will go away for a while and you
will let things cool off and then you
will do a rehabilitation tour
and then you'll get to go back to work
you know the mel gibson playbook
you know or your bill cosby and you know
you'll never work in this town again but
retire
on the island of your choice once you
serve your time in jail
as a rich rich rich rich man
[Music]
great but it don't look good it don't
look good
just such a like a weird flip
from you know
like how wasn't that long ago that he
was
beloved and golden boy yeah yeah i mean
it was it was
two years ago the the world was excited
to see his new hbo show his return to
television
after you know sort of a decade away
making movies
you know and he was excited about it hbo
was thrilled about it and fans were
eagerly awaiting it
and i'm not sure how the nevers is
performing but i don't think very many
people are talking about it
um no but i mean i i don't know if it's
because the quality of the show or joss
whedon or if
it's because everyone's talking about
the other [ __ ] hbo show mayor of east
town eastern
uh that show is getting [ __ ] huge
buzz yeah
i mean they even sketch this week
and it's really good that's a great show
uh do you why have you watched the
nevers
um i have i've seen all the episodes of
the nevers because you know
despite the fact that i have very
serious problems with josh whedon
you know every now and again he'll do a
thing that i like you know or
or there's a turn of phrase or there's a
concept or a conceit
um that i find interesting and it's it's
the exercise at this point of trying to
separate the art from the artist
and knowing full well that while this is
a created by joss whedon show and
produced by joss whedon
there's lots of other people who worked
on it um some of whom i like quite a bit
and so trying to divorce the guy from
the work
especially when it's a collective work
feels like a
sort of yoga that's worth learning how
to do um
it's not great it's uneven but there's
moments of it that i think are really
cool
um this is apropos of absolutely nothing
yes i keep forgetting to bring this up
have you watched them yet
um i have not
um watch it
do i that we could talk about it it's
powerful powerful stuff and
legit horrifying um
but you know it's
there are there are there's there are
there are moments that are as tough as
you know the the tulsa massacre as
depicted in
watchmen um and as some of the
the racist stuff in lovecraft country
it's
very similar sensibility and style to
lovecraft country
beautifully made like [ __ ] gorgeous
show
um but it's i i would be curious to
see your take on it yeah i mean i i
i made a decision like seeing the first
trailers about it
and and kind of reading a little bit
about what it was
of how much of this pain do i need to
take on board
as i you know go throughout my life yeah
you know and how much of
what feels like could be and i haven't
seen it so i don't know
um but could be exploitation of that
pain
for very specific effect um
and it's like it it has become a taste
thing
for me of like you know what i'm just
not in the mood for is
is this is this very specific kind of
violence and this very specific kind of
of of agony and torture and and
and viscera in the same way that like
you know i remember having friends like
you know what i've never been in the
mood to watch schindler's list
and it's like is there a mood for that
um
but you know absolutely like at some
point you do
take on you've reached your limit of how
much sort of holocaust material you
might want
if you happen to be a person of the the
chosen faith
who may or may not have relatives who
have you know perished in
in the holocaust how much of that do you
need to carry with you
in your soul and so i feel like i'm
getting to that point
where i'm like i don't know if i need
more of this anymore
i've i i it was a tough set
not because it's like this is made by
amateurs like it's incredibly well made
but there's
there was a legit concept a concept in
that
show that will legit
has legit scarred me and i will carry
for [ __ ] life
you know every once in a while i meet
people like hey man that [ __ ] shot of
the walrus and tusk when you [ __ ]
zoom out yeah that's my [ __ ]
nightmare fuel like i'll never [ __ ]
scrub that from my brain
and you know i always thought that was
like oh that's charming i legit
ran into something that reminded me of
like years and years ago
jason muse at one point like he was came
in the office and he was so [ __ ]
horrified and haunted and i was like
what happened and he was like
some guy asked me to look at a video
online it was a video of somebody
getting their head cut off
in real life like it was a beheading of
of uh i don't know what he's some some
place was in america
um but he was like still to this day if
you bring it up he's just like oh my god
i
like i still wish to god that i was not
shown that and stuff
there is there's [ __ ] in them that that
i felt like that
you know and and you know i was not
the community depicted in the show
i i it was just horrifying so
you may be wise to stay away but again
like it's not like it's not well made
it's just
like he said it's just like you know
what i i just can't handle
that much like it like you know it took
like jennifer my wife didn't want to
watch nomad land for a long ass time
because she's like
i'm it's going to break my heart i know
it like i know how [ __ ] sad it's
going to make me why do i want to do
that to myself
and you're like well i don't know art
but like i guess we don't have to watch
everything do we
or like the older you get it's one of
those you know what i'm making an
educated decision
which is like maybe good just i don't
know if i need it like i'm i'm
i'm debating if i'm going to watch and
it's not that much of a debate because i
will
but barry jenkins is uh is releasing the
underground railroad
um his series for amazon which is like
this 10-part adaptation of a pulitzer
prize-winning novel
that is about the legitimate literal
underground railroad
and it's like okay well it's a story set
in slavery and it's about that you know
liberation and it's about that
trauma and that that experience
that i ordinarily would probably steer
clear of simply because i
don't really need any more slavery
stories but it's barry jenkins
and it's like and what i've seen of it
is gorgeous and it's beautiful and i'm
sure it's rendered with care and with
you know
great skill and so like i'll give it a
look
um maybe if i'm in the mood for that
um but but yeah like as of late
especially given the last like year and
a half in america
you know how the the number of
depictions
of black pain that i need has uh has
dwindled
precipitously in recent years
um all right back to the news back to
the news um
this past week was a very busy week in
the world of mark miller
who i keep wanting to say his name is
mark milar but i know he's not
we know it's mark miller though but yeah
it's marketable it looks like
phonetically it looks like mark millar
but it's mark miller and you know he's
scottish and i expected some
[ __ ] english or some spin not english
i realize now that is the wrong issue
um one of my favorite comic book writers
of all time
um of course the creator of uh kick ass
and hit curl but
my guy he did amazing work over at
marvel but
i will never [ __ ] forget his run on
swamp thing at dc
that was where i first got introduced to
his work and
i he's you know and he then he went on
to build
his miller verse which he then sold to
netflix for like 30 million bucks indeed
and so the the fruit the first fruits of
that
collaboration with netflix are beginning
to uh to to reveal themselves to the
world
no but jupiter's legacy um
which was a comic book that he wrote um
what's the netflix show
that's a netflix show that's based on
mark millar's thing
indeed i didn't even know is it
superheroes
it's very much superheroes i had no
like i didn't know i knew i saw the
title and honestly i thought it was like
a [ __ ]
tween thing so i just kept going i
didn't know it was [ __ ] mark
mark miller oh yeah yeah i almost did it
right there mark
you almost did it because you kind of
want to um doing it my whole life until
one day he corrected me it was like it's
miller man miller
leave me alone it's [ __ ] miller who's
mark millar
um wow that's uh
well that's good so uh so yeah it was
the
number one show on netflix over the
weekend that it premiered it's you know
and
and both domestically and apparently
around the world um
so muscle talk to him i haven't seen any
of it yet it's been uh
it's been a week and so i haven't gotten
this done like i got the bad batch in
like that's the one that i watched um
but i'll i will for sure get to it and
be able to report back
um but he has delivered an update of all
the things that are happening there's
still
a new kingsman the king's man movie
which is coming out soon
he's hard at work on a six-episode
live-action spy series
um that he's at work with for netflix
i'm assuming
um another of his comics called the
magic order
is back in active development in netflix
as well
that it was initially supposed to go
into production but then they took a
break
for um pandemic related um issues
as many many things did and so they had
a chance to rethink it and soon they're
going back to it
he's writing more comics he's got a book
called american jesus which is coming
into uh
into being in netflix um there's an
animated adaptation of super crooks
um which is a super powered heist comic
about eight super villains
hey can you for one [ __ ] second
stop unfurling all 28 feet
of mark miller's dick
this guy's doing too much when do we get
a piece of the action
you know i guess we need to create a
universe [ __ ]
yeah how [ __ ] successful that guy is
you know what
he's making [ __ ] we're sitting online
talking about it
one of us is winning in this scenario
god damn it it's always the scotch the
the sponge
mark they rule the world they know their
workers
their go-getters they just they take it
all and they leave
we get the what's left the dregs indeed
they are the one percent the scottish or
the one percent of the world we're the
1990s
but yeah basically like he's a good guy
i mean it's not like i've
spent copious amounts of time with him
but i believe he's a very good guy he's
always been a good guy to me and every
interaction that he's had with people
that i know and and like
everyone likes mark miller so is i'm
happy to hear
that shit's going well for him i will
now look at this
jupiter what is it jupiter's rising
jupiter's legacy
jupiter's little [ __ ] thank god you said
that it sounded like honestly i thought
it was like
that [ __ ] um movie that they did you
know the wachowskis did
oh right you that was jupiter rising
wasn't it
[ __ ] i think it was called jupiter
rising
now now i have to look because a that
movie's batshit crazy
yeah where what's his name the mr magic
mike
he plays a cat man or a dog man or
something like that jupiter ascending
jupiter ascending and what is this show
called jupiter's legacy
so i would be forgiven you would be
unlike those two things were related in
some way and in fact i thought it was
rather ballsy that netflix is like
didn't that movie flop hard well we're
doubling the [ __ ] down
let's do more not bad at all apparently
apparently you can't copyright or
trademark the term jupiter mark
i i hear that it belongs to a planet who
is not overly litigious
i think it belongs to all of us is the
point
um what else we got uh let's see um
blake lively and diablo cody
are both teaming up to adapt darkhorse's
ladykiller comic book
for netflix and i'm not familiar with
this title
um blake lively will be playing um
the perfect 1950s housewife who when not
catering to the needs of her family
leads a secret life
as a highly trained killer for hire
she really likes the second job and her
husband has no idea
so it's a little long kiss good night
it's a little bit killing evie
um but also period and uh a little mad
many as well
a little mad many um so yeah it seems
like it it scratches lots of itches
um especially for an actress who's
looking for
a a big role to play and for a writer to
kind of dig into
some fun subversive content
all right so that's happening there are
some departures
on the flash actually roblo cody won an
oscar right
um she did indeed for uh here you know
here's a little inside info ready
what you got a little [ __ ] hollywood
dish
the only reason i ever joined twitter
was because i was reading an
entertainment weekly
that diablo cody tweeted something and i
was like what what is it
what's a tweet and i read her pithy
comment and i was like i can make a
pithy comment and so i
joined twitter as well so whenever i
hear diablo cody naturally of course i
think of
june owenship but i also think of like
she was my bridge
to twitter and it's not like i knew her
it's not like i called her up and i was
like dee
teach me twitter i just honestly i was
like she's young and hip perhaps this is
something i should look into
she was just shipper into the twitter
mountains she just didn't know it
hey hit your wagon to the stars my
friend hell yeah man
do what the famous people do that's what
my grandmother told me
she said you'll never go wrong doing
what the famous people do
unless it's awful in which case bill
cosby she said especially that bill
cosby he's got his head screwed on
straight
those are the comedy albums my mother
let me listen to she wouldn't let me
listen to carlin
she wouldn't let me listen to red fox
these were albums that my father had
bought me and stuff
but i was allowed to listen to cosby
because she always said she's like he
works clean
and i had all of those albums as well
so did i believe me i'm not trying to
you know
i'm just this is no you know what we
should not we should just leave it and
move on
but to my brother russell i was
literally just going to say that i mean
to people of a certain age like again
let's all first agree that
what bill cosby did is horrible yes
we're just talking about there was a
time we didn't know this
and in our childhood enjoyed a whole
side of an album
called to russell my brother who i slept
with
and it's like it's a it's a it's a
it's a classic bit we we can't do this
we should just
i feel like there's people that are like
yeah but like you know
but woody is still dot dot dot i'm not
making excuses for anybody but i do
you know i agree with you that yeah now
there is the particular yoga
of having grown up the era that we did
the age that we are
of discovering that people for whom not
not to say idolized but were deep fans
of
turned out to be some of the worst
people on the planet and so trying to
find a way to square that circle of
i still have fondness for the stuff even
if i can have no fondness for the person
um stuff i purged all that stuff
out of my [ __ ] because i had it i had
it on record
i had it on cassette i had it on cd i
had
you know the [ __ ] itunes versions and
that was it after that
but every once in a while one pops up
because you know unless you
delete or double delete something out of
itunes
you're just doing a random play you'll
you know it'll just grab
and every once in a while like we'll be
in the car driving and
suddenly you'll start hearing oh uh
i used to play buck buck no oh don't
don't don't
oh god such a you know anyway we should
not be talking about this
this is how our show gets canceled mark
they did a 10 minute appreciation on the
classic works of yeah no we're not we're
not
we're not a2 comicbook.com
i don't want to lose those guys that's
all i got comicbook.com anymore
av club we were right yes that's the
only part of the show that they will
show
cosby apologists question mark
uh there are moving on uh there were two
there was announcement of two departures
from the flash the tv show the flash not
the tv show the flash
movies going full steam ahead but tom
kavanagh
and carlos valdez are leaving the flash
um well i mean look it's a big loss
because they've been there well carlo's
been there since day one
and well they've both been there since
day one so it's tom mm-hmm
um but you know
i'm sure they're just like how
how many different ways can i say barry
you gotta do something you know like
it's been seven years um
you know it doesn't seem to be ending
bitterly
no no they're they are both
open too and the show is open to having
them
you know make guest appearances you know
as as time goes on
but yeah to your point like they they
have been doing
different iterations on relatively the
same kind of show
for a long while and at some point as an
artist i have to imagine
you want to try and and exercise
different
muscles and and spread your wings in
different ways
and so they're leaving on what seems to
be good terms according to
flash executive producer showing eric
wallace tom and carlos have been an
integral part of our show for seven
seasons
and will be greatly missed both are
incredible talents you've created
beloved characters that fans and
audiences around the world have come to
love
which is why we are happily keeping the
door open for return appearances
[Music]
um that's good it's a positive thing
yeah um and and you know carlos has been
in and out
for the last season or two like not he
hasn't been there for every episode
they've got a new man in the chair fair
going on
um you know and tom like [ __ ] how
many different times can you how many
different wells's can you play
i mean he's done a lot of them but
they're happy bunch up there i mean i
haven't been up there in years but like
i did three episodes of the flash
you know pretty tight-knit family who
enjoy each other so
it's nice it's
sad that you know all good things come
to an end and
and right now these two guys are heading
off into the sunset although they can
come back and visit and whatnot
but uh it's a happy time for those cats
because they're like all right
what's next like uh los
is a really thoughtful kid and i
remember having a chit chat with him on
set
once like during i think i was there for
the second episode
um that i did and you know he talked
about like
trying to figure out how long he would
stay with the show he's like i love it
here but like
i'm my my 20s are going to be spent
inside this concrete
and you know shouldn't i want to live a
life shouldn't i
you know so he was when i saw that
announcement i was like you know
it makes sense he's also a musician he's
you know
he's got some other things he wants to
do rather than just
vibe it yet again and also what happens
too is if you leave you get to come back
and when you come back you're happy to
see the character and the actor's happy
to be there and stuff and
some big welcome home reunion scenarios
so nothing good is going to come from
this
yeah i mean and it's you know the the
the truth of it is
if you're if you're an actor especially
a young actor and you play your cards
right
and you've had a serious regular role
for seven or eight years
you know sometimes that's all you get
you know not to be like a
purveyor of doom and gloom but like
eight years as a series regular on a
network show
is the jackpot you know if you ever
strike that jackpot again
then it's lightning striking twice you
know not everybody can be
you know robert urich um you know or tom
selleck
who like you know we're gonna keep
making shows for this guy until he you
know passes away
right but if you get a great seven years
in a show that you like with people you
love
um and you can save your money and and
spend it wisely and buy yourself a house
that's not past your means and
and then do the other stuff that you
love and then find you know and maybe
some of that's acting maybe it's other
stuff
maybe it's indie movies maybe it's
whatever but you bought yourself a
ticket
and you know you rode the ride and you
left happy
hopefully knock on wood um
well we wish them well indeed those two
heroes uh tom welling responsible for
one of my favorite performances of all
time
that first season of flash and uh you
know
him playing uh ear bard thong
when he was like run barry
oh [ __ ] i still get chills run barry
run yep so good that
whole first season was so [ __ ]
fantastic
like one of the best first seasons of
television ever produced that i watched
um god it was so good the man in the
yellow
suit oh god now i've made me feel like i
want to go watch that again
remember oh oh my god i'm gonna get
emotional thinking about him [ __ ]
this mom getting killed
so good so good person that show is
[ __ ] fantastic god damn it's so good
um okay what else somebody asked in chat
what's going on can i say anything about
motu
um i believe what is the date the 10th
i believe this week perhaps you may be
seeing
some imagery um
i think some of the first press is
breaking
so i'm not i'm not sure if i'm at
liberty to say
but um there's a preview coming
and uh i did an interview for it and i
know they've i had to approve
images and so i know that you're going
to see some
first the first images ever released
and i think that's this coming week um
but in other news i saw the teaser
trailer
which is [ __ ] phenomenal
they uh they've they've
it's about a minute and a half they
found a piece of music that's just
absolute jeff's kiss is it now
yeah especially with the material um but
it's
it's wonderful and it makes you like it
like i know this [ __ ] series
in in and out and it made me go back and
start watching it again i was like holy
[ __ ]
like that netflix marketing department
they know what the [ __ ] they're doing
man like they that's the trailer i saw
it said netflix creative or whatever the
[ __ ]
and oh it's it's a great spot so i can't
so i
say when you're gonna see it but um if
if i'm
seeing it now then
it's coming fairly soon i guess
is what i'm saying i don't want to get
fired no don't do that
yeah i don't i don't i don't i can't i
don't have that many
number one i don't have the you know
[ __ ] swag that malcolm has
you know he talked he literally talked
about like [ __ ] doors open
he's like that that see three seasons on
empire
puts you in on a list in a room where
people are suddenly like i'm not even
going to read your sample
go like you know it's that crazy over in
this business and stuff
um and you know and that
that he met the challenge you know what
i'm saying like [ __ ]
he doesn't have a long resume especially
based on what we saw
like it's not like oh this guy's been
working forever and stuff like that he
has
but he's not been working in the
business forever and still
turned in something like way better than
anything i could have done
yeah and there's also the weirdness of
hollywood which is
that's a dude even though he says i was
out of the business for a long time
after he breaks back in with empire
i am sure that there's years worth of
stuff that he worked on that nobody's
ever seen
because hollywood is just that way you
know like i pitched i sold i wrote
pilots you know i might have written
movies and some of which got produced
some of which didn't
um but much of which just won't ever see
the light of day
because that is that's the way you can
have a complete career in hollywood
um as a screenwriter writing things that
nobody will ever watch
um and still pay your mortgage and feed
your kids and buy clothes for everybody
and save her retirement that's my friend
brian lynch
you know who wrote like the minions
movies and
and secret life of pets and stuff first
10 years he was out here
he like he wrote script after script got
paid
incredibly well but nothing got produced
yeah
you know i was like oh my god man i wish
i was you just writing scripts that i
get
paid for and [ __ ] nobody ever
criticizes them because they don't get
made and he's like yeah but they don't
get made that's the point of the story
and then he hooked up with illumination
and then everything he did got made and
stuff
so yeah it's it was a good chat today
absolutely all right what else we got we
got one last story
it's a quickie but uh did you ever watch
pennyworth no i didn't the alfred show
young alfred baby
alfred indeed um which is on epics
a cable channel you may or may not have
uh in your in your codery of channels on
your on your remote
um it has done two seasons on epics um
during which i'm not sure how many
people watched it i see it every year
gets
put up for for award consideration um
but the show is now plotting a move from
epx to hbo max
for a potential third season look at
that man that's a vote of confidence
right there
indeed hbo max likes what they've seen
for two seasons enough to be like we'll
take it
yep so part of the deal which they're
still negotiating would involve a new
season three
and additionally the previous episodes
from the first two seasons so you could
have all of it in one place
if you'd like to watch the you know kind
of
weirdly period slash contemporary slash
a little um temporally fluid look at the
origins of
kind of badass british
london chauffeur slash butler slash
bodyguard
slash spy alfred pettigrew
is it uh are there any masks
um uh i don't remember i've seen like
three or four episodes and in those
three or four episodes there were no
masks yet
although you know he does get to hang
out a bit with
young thomas wayne who's a billionaire
in swinging london
as well um so yeah they don't quite
fight
criminal masterminds but it's it's it's
interesting it's worth a look
what uh what year the ones take place
60s 60s london yeah so you get a little
bit of that swinging 60s a little bit of
that uh
you know not quite as cheeky as austin
powers but
it's a little summer of lovie if they
put it on hbo max
they'll get another set of eyeballs from
me ta-da
uh is that the news badass the news my
friend there it is kids
mark brought you the news man you wanted
to hear about the news well
the news has been heard about
thanksgiving
he broke it right here and you can't fix
it it's unfixable
news hey banff boy
it's time for questions
bamf yeah that's expensive sound effect
can only mean one thing
kids time for q a with jc
jc i see you being very active in chat
uh yeah i'm just talking to people
somebody just
somebody just messaged us from moscow
and uh it it sparked uh
sparked something in my head i just
finished watching
which i think mark talked about on the
show like six months ago
the wind of change podcast have you
heard of this
so good right it is so good
it's eight episodes about how the cia
may have written the song wind of change
and given it to the scorpions
it's so good i've heard a version of the
story to like infiltrate and bring down
the soviet union soviet union yeah yeah
really good and that's what it's a
podcast
it's a podcast from uh a journalist
from the new yorker so good
are they talking about turning it into a
movie or series yet
so i don't know
i was listening to it i'm like this
would be better than argo and then in
like episode two he's like
this story reminds me of argo and it's
like well okay this has already been
sold i'm sure
yeah i remember hearing uh like about
six months ago that there was a bit of a
bidding war
to see who was going to get their hands
on wins of change because
yeah like you listen to one episode like
oh i see exactly what this movie is you
know you listen to like four or five of
them it's like oh that took a turn i
didn't expect
you know and then by the time you get to
eight it's uh
it's it's kind of amazing and and a
wonderful wonderful story
so this is i might be doing this for an
audience of one
but uh and i probably shouldn't say this
out loud but what the hell
uh one of my friends used to work for
doc mcgee
and we would go out to the rainbow on
sunset strip
and drink until two o'clock in the
morning
and then go back to doc's office and
in doc's office he literally has a
jar with a million dollars
that he shredded sitting in it so
everything you hear in that podcast
about doc mcgee
is totally believable
anyways endorsing a podcast that has
nothing to do with us
but it's not no that's people people
tune into this show to hear about
[ __ ] they they know about and [ __ ] they
don't know about so you do
you're doing exactly what you should be
uh before we head into the q a though
a lot of people in chat have brought
this up frank mcrae just died
uh frank was an actor in license to kill
and the last
action hero no nfl a player turned actor
who appeared in the james bond film
licensed to kill
and then the last action hero died april
29th of a heart attack in santa monica
he was 80.
um born in memphis he attended tennessee
state university
and he was a defensive tackle for the
chicago bears and the la rams but here's
his list of movies
last action hero hard times norma ray
red dawn big wednesday fist
with sylvester stallone who he also
appeared in with parrot in paradise
alley
lockup and rocky ii
um
he was a national lampoon's vacation i
believe he was the
cop you know who was like he treated me
like a dog mr wally
he took away he's the the the wally
world
security guard with john candy if i
remember correctly
um he was also in uh
1941 batteries not included
and used cars
what a list rest in peace sir yeah
a huge list of movies and tv shows
um a guy who you know was uh
you know he was never the star but those
cats are the glue
the cartilage of a movie man he was so
familiar you saw him again and again and
stuff
you know that's usually the mark of a
quality
uh character actor as you see him a lot
all the time
but sadly you won't see frank mcrae
anymore uh
dead at age 80.
um there is one other piece of news we
didn't cover because it's not expressly
about the
the nerd stuff but it is the ongoing
travails of the golden globes
um which had fought had come under
attack
um about a month ago or so i want to say
by the la times who discovered that like
in the 40-year history
of the globes they've only ever had like
two black members of the hollywood
foreign press association
which has only ever been like you know
40 or 45 people at a clip
um and so uh
after coming under fire they they made
some apparently half-assed
attempt to try and diversify their
membership which fell
um on deaf ears and so all the studios
are beginning to pull out
amazon netflix i think
paramount might have pulled out um
tom cruise has returned his three golden
globes that he won
and i think as of today nbc has canceled
the golden globes
as a telecast oh no whatever will we do
without the golden globes
my goodness it's unclear i think however
we shall persevere
um so strange but at the same time
strange that it even lasted as long as
it has
yeah you know the the the least taste
the weirdest boondoggle but okay it was
an excuse for
famous people to get dressed up um
a banff boy get your ass back bam
yeah uh bamfoy uh
let me ask you this um
goddamn it was in chat and somebody
brought it up and i was like oh [ __ ] i
gotta
i gotta bring that up [ __ ]
something that you did or saw down
yes the schmodown thank you what
happened with schmodown
i i won my schmodown match it was a star
wars match
so it wasn't probably i didn't get any
cool world questions
but um right before the match i was it
was on may the fourth so i was at scum
and villainy
and the manifold on the soda gun
exploded
and so it was spraying freezing cold
seltzer water all over the bar at like
two o'clock in the afternoon so i'm
trying to fix it with duct tape i'm
stretched
then i had to jump in my car sit in
traffic and i got home
just as i was going on the show
and one of the first questions was who
directed rogue one and i couldn't
pull it out of my head and so i've been
getting endless [ __ ]
from everybody for the last week about
who directed rogue one
but i still won i still pulled it off
congratulations my friend thank you
hopefully
now i've been on i've been on twitter
razzing people i'm in the like minor
leagues
so i'm starting to razz people in the in
the real shmo down that i'm coming for
him in the star wars division
um the uh another news story we should
probably
hit on and some people somebody was like
is it news if you just read a dead
person's
body of work uh tawny katane passed away
age 59.
and tony katane you know people of
my generation mark's generation remember
from the
white snake videos cover of rat
albums uh she but uh i saw her
uh first performance i think it was a
first performance
um in a movie theater i went to see
bachelor party
i was saying yes staying at my sister's
college
the summer of 83.
i guess that's when the bachelor party
came out 84.
and yeah right yeah i think that's right
84. and
um like a bunch of the sisters in her
dorm like took me to see
bachelor party which was an r-rated
movie and um
that was the first time i i kind of like
saw tawny katane and fell a little bit
in love with her and whatnot she was in
the perils of gwendolyn which board
um she was in some hercules as well
but uh the music videos you know she was
married to that dude from
white snake for a red hot minute big
junior stuff
but uh she just passed away jen
yeah jen really wanted to name
our daughter tawny after tawny contained
and i said why specifically after johnny
contains
she just thought it was such a cool
80s name she just loved it he very much
is we cannot we cannot so we named her
jocelyn
and we spelled it weird so we could call
her jin like a star wars name
isn't it well a little more on brand
than tony
yeah yeah although jenna and i
don't want to kane uh [ __ ] cantina
it's the scum and villainy cantina
jen and i met at a rat concert though
at the house of blues so it is on brand
that's called oh my goodness at the now
gone house of blessings now gone now
it's a
chase bank and a high-priced apartment
building
right that's what they built there um
all right the q
a begins man jc's gonna pick three
questions me and mark gonna
try our damnedest to answer those
questions to the best of our abilities
uh all right this is uh from fripp25
what do you guys want the next indiana
jones mcguffin to be
um the thing they're chasing
the uh like whether it's the lost ark or
the [ __ ] uh
holy grail or crystal skull
what year is that we don't know
we figured though the last one was the
60s
um i thought the last one was the 50s
because it was an atomic age the last
one was
yeah the last one was the the 50s
because it was
aliens atomic age nuke the fridge
so the next one so i'm in charge of this
hypothetical
indiana jones movie so i get to pick the
era and what they're going after
i feel like it should be yeah like late
60s 70s maybe
i'm going for 70s and it's bigfoot
indiana jones versus bigfoot
he's got to investigate that footage
where he [ __ ] lumbers and then he
looks at the camera and [ __ ]
it's all three it's it's bigfoot the
loch ness monster
and uh was another thing would have been
on in search of
wild boy is it bigfoot and wild boy
meets indiana james
that'd be amazing
it would be bigfoot loch ness monster
and he's done aliens with crystal skull
so i don't want to say like [ __ ]
martians but
dizzy devil um come on mark
keep it real um cults
like remember the rise of satanic cults
so he's dealt with cults a little bit
we're not well you know the dark
versions of religion ie
kalimal and stuff like that without i
think technically that could be
considered a cult right
um it was a a thuggy death cult yeah
yeah i guess
it's on brand um uh yeah i'm saying
my indiana jones movie takes place in
the 70s
and it involves him [ __ ] facing
bigfoot
the loch ness monster and what was the
third thing
um colts and satan
satan banff mary's baby slash
[ __ ] exorcist slash race with the
devil kind of satanism that
sweet sweet 70s satanism
that we all wanted to be a part of
and you know now it's been so [ __ ]
glamorized and like it's so
bougie but back then that was when
satanism was metal kids
boy what do you have to say uh there was
a i believe it was a
star wars tales comic uh probably 20
years ago now
that indiana jones is adventuring
through some the lush
thick jungle trying to find bigfoot
and it turns out bigfoot was chewbacca
and that the millennium falcon had
crashed into this jungle
a long time ago uh and it's super fun
uh mark um i think it's indiana jones
and the titanium hip
[Applause]
because everything ford is not a spring
chicken
that's very true man it honestly it
should be indiana jones meets cocoon
where they're gonna die like i'm gonna
go with them because
i'll never get older and i'll never die
who let this guy into my [ __ ] house
um all right bam boy that's one question
down you gotta feed us another goddamn
question
banff all right uh we got another one
this one is from
um christopher hyde
uh christopher wants to know we have all
the we all have those movie scores
that when we hear we are instantly happy
what would be
on your mount rushmore of movie scores
uh a franchise like star wars
would include it would be like star wars
would be
one thing
i think we killed him
um all right so my mount rushmore of
movie franchises
scores scores only scores we're talking
about the music
it's even easier uh john williams
star wars scores rather it's not the
composer it's the scores themselves are
getting
uh star wars
superman
raiders of the lost ark
and one more from mount rushmore
uh uh batman tim burton 1989 uh
danny elfman's batman score that's my
mount rushmore
okay wait a second yeah because it's not
if it was the composer then williams
would be appearing
three times right not the composer it's
the scores
correct all right superman
star wars the collective star wars
catalog
uh the collective indiana jones catalog
raiders of lost art
and uh and uh danny alfman's batman
score
okay um eat that
eat that with a stick um
basil poldoris is conan the barbarian
score
[Music]
that's a good score um
let's see um [ __ ]
the the star trek ii
wrath of khan score
i like it um which i love um
you have to go faster because zesty clam
in chat just said i know it's free but
god damn this
this is boring thank you zesty clam
sorry um sorry we're we're not
thrill a minute here man yes we had
you know [ __ ] malcolm spellman was
given it now we're in the cool down hour
this is like almost the end of the show
yeah come on man um
don't say nothing at all that's all i
also go
star wars um clearly you can't not go
star wars
um um
[ __ ] you got me thinking about excalibur
now which has
um [ __ ]
see now my my hate keeps getting stuck
with soundtracks now
and so i'm like i would want purple rain
on there or i would want [ __ ] the
muppet movie on there but
the scores of those movies aren't so
great as much as the soundtracks are
great
but you're talking needle drop that's a
whole different mount rushmore that's a
totally different mount rushmore so i
think for my fourth
um i'm going to go
uh harry potter
man
yeah that is a pretty pretty good score
i mean
that's john williams as well isn't it
john williams the king of the square
that you could hum or do out loud
you know what i'm saying like nobody's
saying that about
like [ __ ] philip glass or something
like that or
who's the guy that does the you know
[ __ ] man of steel and stuff
oh yeah huh hans zimmer you can't it's
tough to do
what is what is the dark knight theme
um there there kind of isn't one really
is that right i mean there's there's a
score but
[Music]
and there's like that it's a bit it's
nolani
which means that there's not real theme
because i think they were like the
anti-theme
um it ain't like elfman's
no no no no no
no not even close remember the opening
of batman 1989
just that [ __ ] haunting music like
that score
told you from the opening credits that
like this
ain't we're not goofing around like this
ain't batman you know from the tv show
this is [ __ ] moody because it had
that like
that haunting like something
bad happened
to this boy's past something
bad happened something bad happened
so i'm trying to entertain zesty clan
mark i'm doing my
work man he's he's just decided that
he's just not a fan
i'm playing a zesty clam everyone else
might as well jump off the show
i'm trying to win one heart tonight
starts one mark the dj stole my saved my
life tonight
what about a no ennio morricone on there
i mean good betty ugly is pretty strong
like it's hard to
wear balls
[Music]
a great game show on sci-fi or something
like that guess that what's the score
we had celebrities performing acapella
versions of their
favorite scores legit pitch that that's
a good [ __ ] show man
i'm just saying that's that's just fun
like we could literally [ __ ] like you
just try you go like all right
it's kind of like name that tune but
it's like can you understand the theme
i'm doing
does this make any sense to you yeah
does this sound like something
a bad boy you had some thoughts i was
going to say i mean
lord of the rings is an easy pick or
star wars are
probably would be what i would i would
put but just to be
different i would pick top gun
i think is really strong uh rocky
the rocky franchise is really strong
you know what the bill conti score is
yeah that is pretty and then if it's
franch franchise you get
ludwig redoing it in creed and
updating it um
i was already so you don't have to
[ __ ] tell creed to get me there i was
already on board you're like hey man
what about creed
oh dude i forgot i forgot um
flash gordon by the great queen wow that
was a great score
yeah i mean and it's not even just the
two or three pop songs that are on there
but the whole [ __ ] score
toto score for doom
that's that's not rushmore though i
don't know
it makes me feel good every time i
listen to it you're a rushmore you do
whatever you want yeah it's your rush
more than the dakota nobody goes to
you're much more rush more or less
yes yes jc i was also going to say the
natural
which is the fanfare for a common man
which they use on
in every epic olympics type thing
of course back to the future
who did that it's a goldsmith uh
no uh back to the future is alan
silvestri
sylvestre yeah there it is
i mean also [ __ ] you know
i mean there's some great music in
endgame
yeah agreed i just watched the last hour
of that on the plane on my way home
because why would you goddamn it that
movie is so [ __ ] great
two of my favorite moments in cinematic
history happen
in like the third act of that movie
one is you know [ __ ] cat picking up
the
the hammer and the other
is tony stark you know going and i
am iron man and just the way he
[ __ ] like he has such a [ __ ] you face
when he snaps like
[ __ ] you so awesome
um all right what else we got
bamf okay last question uh
from andrew chambers uh after 38 years i
just read my first
comic book ever the watchmen
what would be your top graphic novels
you'd recommend
to a new reader
uh for me
i would say um
the dark knight returns
seminal batman work by frank miller
i would say mage the hero discovered
by matt wagner i would say
they already said the watchmen correct i
would say
heroes um by kurt bouziek and
alex ross i would say
god loves man kills by
chris claremont am i correct on that got
him
maybe john byrne as well um
i would say uh the longbow hunters
by mike grell um
this is a
nobody ever shouts this out but camelot
3000
by alan moore um anything by alan moore
but you already got you got the watchman
you're already
moving in the right direction was that
alan moore did he do cameras
yeah wow wait now you got me doubting
myself
yeah i'm like 100 sure
mike barr
i was just way wrong you know why brian
bolin was one of the
hardest but still yeah mike barr my god
why the [ __ ] did i i smoked mike barr
away
from camelot 3000 and literally smoked
alan moore
into the chair how strange big and alan
moore though
swamp thing camera 3000 mike bars chem
lab 3000
uh but but alan moore's swamp thing run
um uh
i don't know that's a bunch from me what
about you mark that's pretty good
um let's see why the last man
by brian k vaughan and piaguera um
the sandman by nick gaiman nick
neil gaiman and assorted artists
nick gaiman's is his cousin who's muscle
in the [ __ ]
rich mob boy i'm on
nick gayman come here you go you are a
[Applause]
[Laughter]
um let's see uh kingdom come
great call um
[Music]
all-star superman
by grant morrison um
fearful symmetry um or uh
craven's last hunt i believe that's
another game
um let's see hard-boiled
by frank miller um the subject matter
is jeff darrow yeah hard-boiled
um and sin city
and planetary
i think planetary can can broaden some
horizons a little bit
um but i think all of those are a pretty
good place to start
if you're if you're looking to to dabble
and if your entree is watchmen then then
i think you are you're well served
by any of these choices good sir
oh my god zesty clam popping up with the
[ __ ] criticisms
isn't this list for newbies dark knight
returns and others like it would be too
demanding regarding page layout and
clutter on the page
jesus zesty clam clam the [ __ ] up
you know with a comment come with
something positive
doesn't always have to be something
[ __ ] negative and [ __ ] and also dark
knight returns is on a nine panel grid
and if you can't navigate a nine pound
green it's perfect for beginners it is
not complex at all
listen to that guy that guy
listen to that guy yeah he's a nine
powers of 12 pounds even if it's 12
paddles it's still pretty easy to read
you just can't please this [ __ ] zesty
clan mark
you can't do it i've been trying all
night i've been playing right to him
he'll
he gives me nothing except notes
he's a zesty clan yeah he's more in
zesty
and it's spicy clams what here
maybe there's some sand caught in that
clam that's making a little irritable
i'm just i'm not making any threats mark
but clams
where i'm from clams get shocked
they get casinoed
um is that did we answer i think we
answered
banff boy return banff
uh we did our job can we go home now
can we go to sleep i think we are done
we've been on for a while it has been a
three-hour show
um and we only had a half hour guest
you know we detoured for a while uh we
you know the
joss whedon thing took a lot of time
indeed
um but you know hopefully
[ __ ] hopefully it's not an audience
full of zesty clams hopefully some of
you are happy clams
had a good time tonight if you had a
good time tonight you thank old jc
he's the [ __ ] uh oracle
the barbara gordon who's making this
[ __ ] happen
[ __ ] casting us out into the universe
and [ __ ]
keeping us warm for when we finally get
to return
to the scum and villainy cantina and
take our rightful places behind the bar
and do this [ __ ] live with people
as they get drunk and pretend we're
funny
we thank you jc how's the bar going how
was may the 4th
may the 4th was good we've been we've
been busy
um i mean we can't put a lot of people
in there but
we've had lines every weekend friday
saturdays
so people showing the love which has
been awesome
lines outside the door lines in the
bathroom stalls come on down to scumming
villainy cantina
drug haven on hollywood
i will say on may the 4th
which we're kind of crossing the streams
but um
the hobbits mary and pippen came in yeah
i saw
i saw that in your one of your feeds
what happened there they they came in
to talk about their new podcast and talk
about
being in these big franchises and they
sang the
hobbit drinking songs sitting at at the
bar
so well nice look at you
instantly started pulling down all the
decor and turned it into a [ __ ]
hobbiton
a little trend jumper um yes we thank jc
and you want to thank him for real in
real life
go to the scum and villainy cantina but
be be prepared to wait in line
apparently
yeah where you won't wait in line to
[ __ ] sit here
and worship at the altar i keep pointing
in the wrong direction of the one and
only
[ __ ] high priest of this [ __ ]
give it up for [ __ ] damn it it's so
backwards give it up for mark bernard
on one screen you're right next to me
but over there you're on the other side
give it up for mark bernard
thank you sir i'll be the high priest of
whatever you need my friend
oh [ __ ] then be in my indiana jones
movie you could be the high priest of
the [ __ ] satanic cult and [ __ ]
you're a good cult leader because you've
got a kind face nobody's expecting it
from you
like we wouldn't put you up front you'd
be like his sidekick through most of the
movie but in the third act
we revealed that it was [ __ ] you all
along and nobody suspects
the sweet-faced guy who's got a few
notes about your [ __ ] hbo series and
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
it was him all along with the [ __ ]
nuts
[ __ ] had so many notes should
have seen it coming
he stabbed me with his notes
somebody asked in chat where's the
jeff's kiss shirt
they're coming they're coming
the only person who can [ __ ] do it is
busy so
they're coming i swear to you um i've
seen them and they are
jeff's kiss and and when we have him
you'll be let me tell you something when
i
[ __ ] announce that they're for sale
on the show if i don't [ __ ] sell out
on
day one i'm gonna find all these people
that go where's the jeff's kiss shirt
and be like what happened and they'll be
like we bought them there were only
three of us we just kept saying it over
and over
like i built my entire economy on the
fact that i thought we were going to
move a thousand shirts
some one guy in his house with 500
shirts be like i bought as many as i
could
yes it was a cute joke it wasn't that
great
what they say about fat man beyond cute
joke but it's not that great but you
keep
tuning in and we love you for it ladies
and gentlemen come back next week we'll
do more of the same probably more like
on the weekends or are we finally going
to the bar next week we
might be going who knows we gotta work
it out we'll let you know kids
stay tuned we'll let you know uh in the
meantime
uh that my friends is fat man uh beyond
for this evening i'm kevin smith and i
am mark bernardin
and you are the people that should tune
in
same next week same bat same bat
fat time same fat channel and that fat
channel of course is smart death
with god damn it i can't a [ __ ] witch
took my tongue mark
podcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith jeff's kiss kids
you